foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by YouTube shorts
Minneapolis Minnesota and check that out
check out that beer brew look at that
Brewery build Ripken Grain Belt beer do
you ever have some of that I don't know
I'm usually sticking with the
Anheuser-Busch products okay okay here
we go that is nothing to do with
anything Hall of America that's where
the Metropolitan Stadium used to be and
Mall of America and beautiful
Minneapolis look at that shot now I've
been to that mall I bet you have and
it's jumbo yeah I've heard that you need
a uh a bike or a cycle to get you need
something a gorgeous shot look at that
shot my goodness so now Target Field
where the Twins and the White Sox will
face off today you got the top of the
division the White Sox the bottom the
Twins and um you're gonna see it right
here coming up you're watching the
pregame show right here Bill Ripken I
mean
you take a look at this White Sox team
that you're going to see today and you
you know we're going to interview Liam
Hendricks a little bit later on about
some of the size of the guys on that
team and every guy it's like it's like
those old dolls where you fit one inside
the next the nesting dolls whatever they
call them that's what they call them
every okay I'm a little educated a
little every guy is bigger than the next
guy they can rake man they can
absolutely rake they got some big dudes
and I don't think there's any question
they're a pretty complete team when you
look at them the starting staff I like
them an awful lot you got to like the
offense you like the bullpen so where is
the downside I don't necessarily see one
um I think right now they are probably
the favorites to maybe go ahead and
represent the American League as they
stand right now am I going too far out
there uh I don't know that I would agree
with you I think that they're clearly
going to the postseason I don't think
that's a question who do you got favored
over that I would say I would say Tampa
Bay or Houston ahead of them I I like I
like them not necessarily mad at you but
I'm going to disagree with you a little
bit I think they're pretty complete you
can I would I would throw you this I
would throw you this other than playing
the last place teams in each division of
the AL the Chicago White Sox are
basically a 500 team they're 23-5
against the O's Rangers and twins 23-5
against everybody else they're what one
game over two games over I worry about
that I do worry about that well but if
as long as you're over and you're
playing a five game set and you win
three and the other team wins two yeah
you move on okay and you can do it again
I see we're doing math let's do this how
about highlights of last night's game
1-1 Abreu hits one deep left Center
gone into the bullpen they go back to
back that'll get us to deal to the plate
for the man aboard
down the line and deep hosta Dio puts
the twins in front
home run number six for La Tortuga
flipped it right in the seats what a
what a nice swing and a nice at bat by
La Tortuga
man oh man you know our friend here uh
John Hart the former GM when he sees a
player who he loves he says that's what
they look like that is not what they
look like but he can hit but he would
also say he's a bit of a guy so
sometimes it's not necessarily what they
look like but can they play so you got
to look at that sometimes no question
how about Eloy Jimenez I mean that's
what they look like my goodness I mean
talk about easy power man it's insane to
me yeah and look he's a big dude I said
this yesterday Big Jim Tomy says he hits
stuff hard now Big Jim's got 612 of
those big balls and flying around the
baseball yard going into the seats he
knows what he's talking about let's take
a look at him the other day and we gotta
how to pad your stats now I know it's
not that easy but this guy makes it look
that easy and I think he's realized in
his young career he doesn't have to try
to do too much that ball is just
absolutely hammered to right center
field this ball is a sanker down and in
and how to pad yourself that trade here
he had two games four homers and ten
ribbies now nobody at the end of the
year if he hits 30 and drives in 100
he's going to go oh but he had four and
ten in two days no no one's gonna say
that so pad your stats and when you're
hot put up numbers like this guy and not
anybody can just go out there and throw
four homers up and 10 ribeye steak
sandwiches in a two-day period that ball
is absolutely squashed on a Up and Away
slider that he does all the power
providing at 85 miles an hour you watch
this thing spinning up the home plate
saying hit me hit me hit me what did he
do he hit him he beat him to the spot
which is the glove there was point A to
point B in this swing this when he
climbs the ladder and jumps up on a 92
mile an hour heat peace and hits it in
the seats but how to pad your stats it's
not that easy and I'm having a little
fun with it but this dude going back to
what Jim said he hit stuff hard and I
noticed in what you just did it's right
it's center it's left that that I mean
to me that's Albert in a way I mean
there's a little Albert in him in which
the easy power right and he can go to
all Fields well I think you'll find in
this league the better hitters are the
ones that you cannot sit there and
overshift on because they have to you
have to honor this line to that line and
everywhere in between and I think that's
why they're the best sitters because the
proverbial hit it where it's pitched
it's kind of what he does that's
textbook Up and Away slider that's
spinning right here in in the middle
part of the plate outer third that he
jumps to dead center field that should
warn everybody oh he's not pulling off
of that he's not popping it up over
there because he's trying to hit it nine
miles that way he just took a nice easy
pass at a ball that's already elevated
he had a long long way to Dead Center
Field Minnesota not easy to do he did he
did so he's buying cleanup today and
Jose Abreu is batting third today and
MLB game of the week poll presented by
YouTube shorts who will win today's game
White Sox or twins Reynaldo Lopez is now
on the mound today so uh no Lance Lynn
Carlos rodon was put on the IL so they
moved things around a little bit Lynn is
going to start the game in Iowa tomorrow
but rodon on the IL was shoulder fatigue
that's not a great sign this time of
year but I'm guessing they're being very
careful knowing that they have a very
large lead in that division so thoughts
before we hit a break here real quick
you have five seconds love those guys on
the grounds crew making that field
pretty for us to go out there and play
on we'll be back
because he's so good with the glove Tim
will try to throw him out and he got him
what a play what an arm
[Applause]
Hernandez will glove it long throw and
he got it
I don't know what to call that I mean
it's a 4-3 ground out but come on you
might as well go 9-3 because it was
pretty much in right field that was a
fine play
Vaughn will leave his feet and he's got
it
to end the inning he hasn't played a lot
of Rights and a nice catch to end the
inning
[Applause]
10 to the glove side
playing some sparkling defense on the
spin move that's Gold Glove kind of
stuff what a play by Tim let the home
Fly ball well hit
done what'd you say about power that is
an enormous Insurance home run congrats
Cesar Hernandez his first White Sox home
run under pugs against the crosstown
Rivals look that is a terrific addition
to this ball Club
so we don't miss
welcome back to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by YouTube shorts
and we welcome in Liam Hendricks of the
White Sox the closer for that first
place team in the AL Central and we're
going to get right to the elephant in
the room and now let's make this clear
here I'm not calling Craig Kimbrel an
elephant however I'm going to ask you I
saw the quotes that you had after the
acquisition about just wanting to win
you don't care you just want to win did
it take you a little time to get to that
point when you heard about the
acquisition
uh not really because at the end of the
day I well like 2019 kind of my my one
of my better years I started as the long
guy I didn't care what role I had I just
wanted to pitch and that was the mindset
I needed to take into it uh when I get a
little bit egotistical when I get a
little bit kind of hard-headed that's
when I start struggling and one of the
things I want to make sure is I never
want to feel it like I never want to
feel like I just have to be given
something all right so I've done
anything it's it's no I got to earn it
every single day and then this is going
to keep keep pushing us both I think
because now we've got a little uh little
strikeout record just to just to attack
each other and see who wins well I'll go
with the elephant in the room too it's
the mug in the hand we're working on
coffee number two so whether it's the
seventh eighth or ninth you got that
12-10 game going on uh today do you
maintain this coffee flow all the way
through or do you take a little break
somewhere
uh so once I finish this one I'm gonna
go have another donut and get another
coffee and then I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
take another one out to the field with
me and then uh we've got a bullpen
dinner plan for tonight so I'll have a
couple night caps after that with coffee
because I don't drink at all so I gotta
swash it all down with some coffee so uh
yeah it I'll probably end up usually on
average of about seven or eight cups in
a day oh that's uh that's healthy by the
way I like it I want to point that out
and the donut on top of it makes it even
better I even like that more I know you
do in fact the three of us would get
along great if we ever hung out together
so I just had my uh cardigan Donuts from
where Minnesota cutting a Donuts from
out here they have a uh a Miami Heat
which is a mango with some chili peppers
mixed in there as well it was delicious
wow well
um you know look your GI system is going
to have a really hard time with this but
let me go to this though when you're on
the mound
um we appreciate the the fire the
intensity and look I talked to you off
camera a couple of years ago in Oakland
you are not the guy we see on the mound
during a game how do you how do you kind
of turn it on turn it off because you're
a pit bull man
yeah so I've it took a while for me to
get to that point but off the field I
like to joke around I like to have some
fun on the mound I'm old business and
kind of get a little angry but um I I
was talking to Corey provas the radio
broadcaster here with the twins
yesterday and I was saying it's like
every little thing that a hitter does is
a slight and annoys me so then I just
get angry with a little thing whether
they try and bunt whether they swing too
hard whether they look the wrong
direction whether they didn't say hello
as I'm walking to the bullpen every
little thing I'm just looking for that
little bit of extra angst and anger that
I can use against them and uh and then
you can tell when I'm really mad because
my skin goes really really red Liam talk
a little bit about the squad you're on
because uh we sit here from a distance
and we see kind of a complete team I
don't think there's any question about
that do you guys feel the same way when
you're walking in that clubhouse that
whatever day it might be one part of
this team whether it's the offense the
defense the starting pitchers the
bullpen they seem to always be able to
pick up the slack but it's a pretty
complete Squad you have
yeah it's it's amazing obviously the
only the only downfall of this is the
fact that batting practice is no longer
any fun for me to kind of shag balls in
the Outfield because nothing comes back
but um yeah I mean what we were able to
do with this year with uh our pitching
staff held us earlier with a couple of
injuries and now the lineup's coming
back can you see what the numbers we've
been able to put up offensively and it's
it's fun man it's a good team it's but
the biggest thing about this team that I
think is is the pivotal to success right
now is the fact that we just rag on each
other at all times I make fun of each
other at every single time we don't let
anybody get big-headed we don't let
anybody get egotistical and we just make
sure everyone uh knows that we're all in
this together no matter who does well
that day you know what you're talking
about getting your lineup back uh hit on
a little bit some of the young guys that
uh when your big pieces were out of the
lineup some of the young boys coming up
uh they had their hand in quite a few
wins as well so talk a little bit about
that the the guys that stepped up when
some of the guys were out of the lineup
yeah I mean yeah you look at Andrew
Vaughan
um he was a guy who was up possibly stay
and then Eloy went down unfortunately
and they told him with two days or three
days left to go on Camp hey let's try
out left field ran out there and was
able to kind of nail it down and then
you mix in the guys like they were up
and down with Danny men the exact
Collins has shown he can uh can work on
things throughout the course of the year
I mean he's looked a lot better like
behind the plate these last couple games
and just shows the work ethic that he's
putting in but yeah we've had just it's
unbelievable the next guy up mentality
the guy the guys that have come up here
and I think that plays into the whole
mentality we make fun of everybody we
don't care if you've got 10 15 years in
the big leagues or if it's your first
day we're still going to make fun of you
so you know that there's a family in
here and that's just the I think that's
the it has it's worked so far this year
and hopefully it can continue on for the
rest of the year yeah but if you're
making fun of people who are twice your
size that could be dangerous I mean I
have never seen on television anyway a
baseball team with bigger people in my
entire life every guy is bigger than the
next guy I mean you walk in that
Clubhouse I mean you're not small do you
walk in there and say what the heck is
going on around here
why just make sure to stand next to
Billy Hamilton so he makes me feel big
but yeah this team's the monsters this
team's the monsters from Space Jam it's
a joke it's not it's not it's not fair
it's not right but I mean it's it's one
of those things where we go out there
and regardless of the size I mean eloy's
just a big big baby as everyone calls
him and it's just now I get a chance to
see that full time and and the guy
doesn't stop smiling and that's just
that attitude that we love that's great
um Iowa coming up you got that game
tomorrow in Iowa and I saw a great quote
from you do you remember or do you know
which one I'm talking about regarding a
home run do you know you what I'm
talking about yeah yeah I don't want to
be the first guy to give up a homer the
big league Homer in Iowa
yeah right there's still time
um the good thing is I'm never going to
be the first guy to give up a walk-off
home because we're the home team so
there's that so exactly no that's a
great call so that's going to be a whole
lot of fun Hey listen
um really really important stay healthy
have fun and I hope you get to that
World Series man because you put in your
time and you've gotten into the
postseason maybe this is the year Liam
Hendricks thank you
thanks guys appreciate it thanks Liam
time now for our creator Spotlight and
we welcome in Andy Leone also known as
Andy Rulo check out the channel name
Andy Rulo and it's MLB gaming videos and
behind the scenes Vlogs of Dodger film
softball games his favorite team the
Mariners he's been waiting a while to
get to the playoffs we know that and the
favorite moment for Andy the 2012
perfect game thrown by Felix Hernandez
the only guy to ever do that in Mariners
history welcome welcome into the show
great to have you hey let's talk about
the game folks are going to see today
the White Sox and the twins and your
favorite players on each team who are
they
um I'd say for the twins I'd say Byron
Buxton
um love a good center fielder I know
he's not on the field right now but when
he gets healthy and he's out there and
he's flying around center field doing
his thing love it
um and then for the White Sox I probably
say Tim Anderson
um just because he's unabashedly himself
out on the field there he brings a swag
he brings that that new style of
baseball that uh the kids hopefully love
I love it so yeah I love Tim Anderson
yeah the kid the kids do love it but he
certainly certainly exciting to watch
and uh some people they say no no no
that's that's not old school we I don't
like that but he's actually not in the
lineup today they're giving him a day
off
um but give me your take on your ends
your Mariners uh this season you're
hoping really like dude they really have
a shot to get in is what I'm asking
we we were right there uh like a game
and a half behind I think the A's for
that first Wild Card like a week ago and
we dropped down a little bit all the
pieces are there all the pieces are
there all the young pieces I'm a big
Kyle Seeger guy so you got that veteran
leadership
um hopefully hopefully we pick up the
club option for him next year and we
keep things rolling we build off of this
year we'll see I don't know it could be
it could be a fluke Mariners are going
to be the Mariners I really never know
what to expect I mean that 20-year
drought playoff drought 19 years
whatever it is now I don't know too long
so we'll see yeah they're five and a
half games out of the wild card and I am
I am with you on singer by the way not
nearly enough attention that guy is a
gamer I'm a big fan as well so back in
2012 when Felix through his perfect game
I know that's big for you as a fan where
were you and your memories of that what
are they
so I was home I remember I had just
woken up it was a day game
um I think I was browsing Facebook and
all of a sudden one of my my friends was
like hey Felix is doing something turn
on the TV and I was like okay whatever
and it was like the seventh eighth
inning and I was like oh okay this is
going on you know you don't say perfect
game obviously I'm super superstitious
and uh so I'm sitting there counting the
outs and then probably around like two
three outs to go
um I noticed I remember my little
brother was mowing the lawn in the
backyard I was like I don't want him to
miss this because my older brother was
the reason that I missed Randy Johnson's
perfect game I was just in the other
room and he didn't want to be like he's
superstitious too he didn't want to be
like hey come check this out something's
happening and then like I heard him
celebrate and Randy Johnson got a
perfect game and I peeked my head around
the corner and I'm like what happened so
I missed that I didn't want my little
brother to miss Felix do this so I went
I yelled at him I got his attention he's
mowing the lawn uh he comes in he's like
what's happening is it a perfect game
and I'm like shut up shut up shut up
like don't yeah you know but uh you know
he obviously got the perfect game we
were hooting and hollering and stuff my
mom was there and yeah it was it was
awesome it's crazy how time flies that's
almost a whole decade ago insane so your
YouTube channel with the video of the
softball games uh tell us more about it
in your favorite moments
all right so I like to uh wear this
helmet actually I got it right here so I
attach a GoPro to this little John
Olerud helmet shout out to John ulrude
love him Commander's Legend
um
attach a GoPro to that and I'm just out
there you know goofing off saying
whatever you know you and you're out
there playing with your friends you're
saying crazy stuff dumb stuff just funny
stuff just goofing off and uh and okay
here you go you're showing a video of
what I like to call a Dinger Heist went
over the fence brought that one back
nice yeah it's just stuff like that is
there you go yep yep getting props from
Cowboy Jeff right there he's been on
this before
boom yeah just hitting dingers doing my
thing
um that's good very cool with my
softball buds yeah that's cool and also
you know with the video uh you can't you
know you can't dog it man you gotta
hustle because they'll be video proof
that you are not giving it your all I
just want to point that out
true true I'm always hustling I'm always
hustling I love getting out there I love
playing I actually play in a pair of
sandals everybody gives me gives me a
grief for it but I play in like
legitimately like a pair of like Teva
like sandals and it works we're been
working out great for me and that catch
right there that was that was in sandals
right there are we talking flip-flops or
sandals with like a like a strap on it
they like they they they strap on you
can kind of see them right you kind of
see them right there for a split second
see there you go yeah there's a little
strap on them they're attached to my
feet
yeah that might be a new thing at some
point I don't know the game is changing
but I don't know I don't know if it's
going to change that much Andy we thank
you for your time and good luck and keep
keep moving on with that girl with that
GoPro that's a whole lot of fun
thanks man appreciate it
well coming up the game here on YouTube
Ronaldo Lopez On The Hill today a late
change in the rotation you'll see Lopez
number 40 on the hill
and a high-fly left field off the bat of
Garver he has touched off a three-run
home run with two out Garber puts the
twins in front the 2-2 a swing and a
drive into right field and deep down the
line that ball is going to be fair and a
home run a three-run ninth inning shot
down the right field line
[Applause]
catch near the foul line
and a high fly to right field
way back and gone and the twins break it
open home runs 19 and 20 today for
Polanco number 20 a big one with a
couple of men aboard
bare-handed and so now threw him out
what a play by Miguel sonota and the
game it was do or die for Sano he came
charging in grabs it with that big right
hand and throws a bullet right on the
money to Garber at first base what a
terrific play
[Applause]
welcome back to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by YouTube shorts
it is time now for picks to click
presented by bet MGM are you ready I'm
ready I'm all over this I think I'm 144
out of 148 out of the 148 that I've done
this year that is very that's actually a
very good percentage thank you all right
the American League pennant and the
White Sox are first up here uh plus 275.
do they win the AL Crown I told you that
at the beginning I think they're the
favorite in there so I'm going to say
yes to the White Sox I know anything can
happen when it comes to postseason play
I like this squad and I'm going to go
with it okay
um I don't think that would be insane
for you to say that Al Cy Young Award
and we have three White Sox pitchers on
the board here Lynn rodon and giolito
will any of them win and if not who will
win there's a lot of baseball to go but
you know what if I'm Taking My Chances
with three of them into the mix
um Lucas obviously looks a little bit
more like the long shot there but I'm
say you know what maybe
no I'll say yes one of them is going to
win it okay one of them uh you want to
tell us which one or you want to skip
that part no I said one of them because
that was the question the way it was
posed To Me Maddie okay I understand now
Rodan by the way on the IL with shoulder
fatigue Al Rookie of the Year and Andrew
Vaughn is part of this conversation plus
800 for rookie of the year so probably
not as good of odds when you're sitting
there looking at that so I'm gonna have
to say no on that one uh there's too
many in that field right there that are
A step above them right now now anything
could change in two months I get that
but I'm gonna say no as of right now I
know it's so funny we're acting like Oh
The Season's ending no it's not no it's
not like seven weeks a lot of ball
today's game Eloy Jimenez uh bases total
bases one and a half
um now walks are not included they are
not they are not is he over or under one
and a half total basis I love the way
this goes because you can throw out a
lousy double he can jam on on a right
field line for a two bag hit he can hit
a ball in the gap or a two bag yet he
can go one for four yeah with a double
sure and he's over so I stay over on
this one okay very good and the final
one for you is the over under and run
scored today in the game total uh both
teams combined nine and a half are you
going over nine and a half or under nine
and a half uh you have to lay 110 to win
one I I hear you on that one and you
know what I'm gonna actually say over I
think there's going to be some runs
scored in this game White Sox lost
yesterday right they're not gonna be
real happy about that correct they got a
little bit of offense they could go out
there I'm gonna say over okay even a day
even in a day game where they they want
six to four is a ten spot I could easily
see that playing out okay very good I'm
just uh checking in with you on that
thank you a second time all right so now
we Roll Along here as you see um uh the
fans interacting with players MLB game
of the week poll results who's gonna win
the game and overwhelmingly the White
Sox 81 I
I'm gonna go first here
are you jumping in with the 81 I agree
oh yeah yes I'm in with the 81 and where
are you I like to fly my own way
sometimes and kind of be solamente but
I'm gonna go with the 81 on this one too
very good White Sox you're not gonna
lose two in a row and they're Braves in
the lineup today Jack uh talk to me
about the MVP he's awesome I love
everything about this dude and I think
he's a good influence for everybody on
that Squad the man plays every day post
up last season when he won MVP he played
60 games guess how many games were in
the season last year 60. and guess what
else he did that I really like he drove
in 60 runs that's one a day so I think
this guy goes up to home plate he knows
how to do things he's got 84 Stakes now
in a year where he's not playing that
well when it comes to that 249 average
but when you look at somebody that's 22
home runs on a year and he's got 84
Stakes that means when guys are out
there he's willing to hit a Sac fly he's
willing to put the ball in play to maybe
the the second basement on this side to
get a run across own plate and runs
matter you score these things right your
head that's what I like cross home plate
if you're not scoring one drive in one
and I think Abreu does both of them very
well
um you know the other thing I like about
him and I'm going to go back a couple of
years I think when he decided to stay in
Chicago he said I want to win here yeah
and he saw what was coming but there's
something to that a guy who doesn't jump
at money and say I'm going to go check
out this city and this he said no no no
I'm good I love it I want to win here do
you do you like that well I think we
still pretty well off yes he wasn't paid
I hear you I like it and I also like
that the fact that the White Sox looked
at him and said you know what this is a
guy we can build around and the fact
that he goes out there and plays every
single day look he's been doing it for a
while his his 162 game average he hits
33 homers and drives in 115. so this
last year wasn't a fluke when he won the
MVP be this year driving and runs this
is what the man does he stands in home
plate and he says you know what I could
be the guy and I think when they get
into the postseason they've got a lot of
Firepower they've got a lot of weapons
on the offensive side who does some
things that dude standing in the
batter's box is going to do something
big compost sees yeah I agree with you
he is a winning player in my opinion he
does look he may not be the fastest
right he may not be the best defender he
may not be this he mean he's a winning
baseball player and as far as that first
base bag goes too he's pretty good over
there he might not be the best Fielder
out there but he's a pretty good staple
when you go out there and play every
single day people are thinking on that
White Sox team count on him every single
day as well well we're going to get you
out to the game right now the MLB game
of the week presented uh by YouTube
shorts Scott Braun the Troy Hawkins and
Lauren Gardner on the scene in Minnesota
for Bill Ripken I'm Matt yelloff enjoy
it's good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
temperatures are summer-ish and
baseballs are flying in the midwest led
by the division's finest making a stop
in Minneapolis two franchises with High
Hopes entering the season have been
living very different realities and now
the world's watching this is the MLB
game of the week Live on YouTube
presented by YouTube shorts It's the
Chicago White Sox taking on the
Minnesota Twins to conclude a three-game
set at Target Field and this division is
all about the White Sox it's been the
case all season long they're the only
Club in baseball with a double-digit
division lead the twins are sweller
seller dwellers after wearing the AL
Central Crown the previous two seasons
and we are thrilled to be here with you
from the ballpark Scott Braun along with
my good friend LaTroy Hawkins yes the
YouTube game package is psyched to be
now at the ballparks for the rest of
this season it feels good the smells are
good you can feel the live action as
we've been doing this from Studios for a
long time now it's good to see you
person LaTroy it's good to see you in
person and not behind a green screen of
something going on but it's great to be
at the Ballpark and as you can see the
fans excited to be at the Ballpark
that's right that's real behind me
that's really Target Field okay so hello
to everyone watching worldwide on
YouTube and welcome to an AL Central
battle between a Chicago White Sox team
that leads to the division by 10 and a
half games we just showed you and you
know they've been doing this without two
of their Big Boppers for most of the
Season Luis Roberts back not in the
lineup today but Eloy Jimenez is back in
the lineup and he's crushing baseballs
right now yeah he's swinging a bat well
I mean he's a he's a banger he's one of
those guys he's going to come in he's
going to get his home runs and what he's
done since he's come back from the DL
he's he's given the White Sox that added
power not like they needed it but the
added power is much welcome and he's
just a Progressive fresh air in that
lineup for them and a nightmare full
opposing pitchers and he's made it to 50
home runs in his career faster than any
other player in franchise history it
took 180 seven games to pull it off he
by far tops the number that Jose Abreu
put together to get to 50. and then for
the Minnesota Twins yes it's been a Down
Season one consistent Force though who's
in the lineup just about every single
day and who's been on fire since July
Jorge Polanco who also switch positions
this year too yeah Jorge Polanco has
been great he's been a staple in the
lineup and on the field and and Rocco
bardelli mentioned doing his interview
with us that he's healthy you don't get
a chance to see that he was a guy in
2019 he started the All-Star game at
shortstop and he was healthy then he has
some angle injuries but not to the point
where he couldn't play it just limited
his production so he's back pulling the
ball with authorities hitting the ball
out of the ballpark he's out there every
single day and he's been he's a leader
in the clubhouse for this team so you
can see it as numbers since the second
half what he's been able to achieve
Rocco baldali calls in a lead by example
guy and you can see the season breakdown
from June through August 300 plus 15
home runs 40 RBIs a Deal's healthy for
the first time in a few seasons and it
is showing right now and also a part of
our broadcast team today we're thrilled
to have Lauren Gardner joining the party
LG hello
yeah Scotty it's been a minute since the
White Sox have won the AL Central in
fact this is one of the longest active
droughts in baseball as we take you back
to the last time they clinched with a
game 163 playoff contest or play in
contest weather where they beat the
twins one nothing it was Jim Tomy who's
responsible for the long run in the ball
game which was a solo shot in the
seventh inning a very emotional victory
for this club they of course went on to
lose the raise in the division series
but when you talked to Tony larussa
about that year versus this year of
course it's apples to oranges they have
a 10 and a half game lead in the
division but he said we're not taking
anything for granted we are not going to
Coast down the stretch because of course
you have to respect the game and your
opponents and he said if we played then
like we're playing now we probably won't
go that deep into the postseason so
there's a lot to focus on there's a lot
to work on but them getting healthy at
the right time you look at this rotation
you look at the Bullpen this might be
one of the most complete teams in
baseball and of course there's Skipper
said we love the cliche the baseball
Gods guys are always watching all right
we're gonna step aside when we come back
we have starting lineups and first pitch
here from Target Field and Minnesota
beautiful day here in Minneapolis fans
getting ready for an early first pitch
[Music]
Mr Right
it's deep and it's gone
two run Homer Tim Anderson it's three
nothing
[Applause]
yes and the center it's going to get
down everybody should Advance one it's
an RBI hit for Tim his third of the
night but thin starts to get hot the
ball Club starts to get hot
because he's so good with a glove Tim
will try to throw him out and he got him
what a play
Tampa to base hit there's the Salvage
it's eight to four six foot right-hander
fires away first pitch swing and a drive
out into right well hit it's gonna
oh one pitch one run
Sox lead one ZIP well that's what you
call instant offense Tim Anderson
leading It Off
2-1 driven in the air deep Right Center
that Ball's going to get to the wall
sits right on the track in and out of
the Ivy and it's a double for ta a three
head Knight
[Applause]
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts
watch and create videos on YouTube try
shorts in the YouTube app on your phone
and we are streaming live globally on
MLB's YouTube channel it's free tell
your friends over 3 million subscribers
to this channel also can receive
notifications prior to upcoming games
like the one that's just about to begin
and make sure you can check out our new
feature you can choose your own
listening experience on your favorite
devices by selecting primary home or
away in the audio track settings that's
brand new we'll talk more about it as we
continue along in YouTube TV customers
you know you're all hooked up it's in an
MLB pop-up within the channel guide and
let's go Toe to Toe Head to Head tail of
the tape well it's been lopsided Le Troy
not only has Chicago taking 13 of 18
matchups but the 123 runs are the most
scored by a team against a single
opponent this season AKA they're having
fun with twins pitching yes they are and
it's you can see the 123 runs it's just
you know they have a very explosive
offense and if you don't pitch them like
similar to the way that Griffin Jax
picks pitched him last night what a good
breaking ball and a swing and Miss
you're going to give up your share of
home runs against this team and they're
going to put the ball in play but I
think what's made them this much better
this year is when the teams have shifted
them they're Big Boppers like Anderson
or braillou they've been able to hit the
ball the other way they're going to take
what the team gives them they're just
not going to continue to hit into the
shift and they are led by the oldest
active manager one of the most senior
managers we've ever seen in the game
Tony larussa is 76 years old third
oldest to ever manage a major league
baseball game and he's also a third most
all-time and wins behind Connie Mack and
John McGraw we had a nice convo when
Tony for about 45 minutes this morning
he also managed this White Sox Club back
in 1979 through 1986 they let him go
there was some regret well guess what
fast forward to 2021 he's back
yes he's back in our like you said our
interview with him today was very
inliteful
um I've never had a conversation with
him now besides hi and by never sat down
and had a real conversation with him and
it was very enlightening to listen to
how he thinks about the game and you
know using his mind his eyes and
trusting his gut and things like that so
you know what I just I was a little
weary when he went over to manage this
very young talented team and after talk
after seeing what they're doing this
year I don't have any worries at all
he's letting those guys go out there and
play the game the way they've used to
playing it didn't try to change anybody
you just sit back watch and add a little
bit here and there you've seen it all
he's relaxed and why not when your Club
is in first place by 10 and a half games
your YouTube shorts starting nine from
Tony larussa's Squad features Cesar
Hernandez the switch hitter somewhat of
a new addition Andrew bonds at first
base Abreu will DH today Jimenez has
been the big bat nine for 22 in his last
six Brian Goodwin's done a nice job in
right field Adam engel's having a big
powerful season Jake Lamb gets to start
at third leori Garcia is at Short and
Zach Collins catches today
so we have the oldest active manager and
then Rocco baldelli is the youngest he's
39 years old and I know they don't have
Nelson Cruz anymore but when he was
there he's younger than Nelson Cruz the
third year manager of Minnesota 186 up
150 down back-to-back division titles
this year not so much the case but when
you talk to people around the
organization and ask them what has kept
this club together this year the answer
is Rocco baldelli yes it is but he like
he he didn't want to take the credit for
it but it all starts at the top and the
leader and he's the leader of the team
the manager and you know his words and
his ability to reach the young players
and and sell them on you know what we
were one of the older team now we wanted
to get one of the younger teams we're
going to go out there we're going to
focus on the fundamentals we're going to
get all that extra work in and I want
you guys to get used to putting in that
type of work and next year we'll see
where we're going to be and they'll test
out some of the young players like this
one Bailey Ober the rookie making his
13th career start he's been better since
the month of July 499 on the season but
since July it's 4-2-3 and he is tall in
fact he's six foot nine one of ten
pitchers all time listed at six nine or
taller to ever start a game that's why
I'm so excited in addition to you being
my friend and us being now together back
at the Ballpark again LaTroy is the fact
that I get to watch Bailey over pitch
next to a former pitcher and this guy's
different yeah you know the height his
ability to use his length and to his
Advantage because he's not throwing 95
96 97 miles an hour you know he's he's
reaching out there and by the time he
releases the ball he's halfway down the
mound and looks like it's a lot harder
than what it really is well there it is
93 it might feel like 96 or seven 98
even
Cesar Hernandez the lead-off man coming
off a season when he led the American
League in doubles this year a
career-high 20 homers yes we're underway
Live on YouTube watching globally it's
all free it's right here Scott Braun
LaTroy Hawkins and Lauren Gardner with
you today
Hernandez a good on base percentage guy
gold Glover last year won the award for
the first time in his career and you've
already seen some of the differences on
defense for the White Sox in the past
week or so
with Hernandez back along with Luis
Robert Manning Center Field these days
he gets the day off today he played a
couple games in the first two of this
series but suddenly a defensive boost
for a team that is already leading the
division he is a game changer in
Centerfield that guy's very impressive
his size his speed his strength his
ability to throw
and you know Goodwin filled in while he
was on the DL the IL you know early part
of the season did a great job but
they're very excited to have Louise
Roberts back in the lineup and I'm
excited to watch him play I mean two
players that won Gold Gloves last year
suddenly added back into the fold
payoff pitch from over swinging a Miss
there's 94 pretty much down the pipe but
it has a bit of a different feel some
extra life to it let's start fastball
four-seam fastball has a lot of carry on
it and it looks like it's a lot harder
and you get a lot of guys swinging
straight through that and he's one of
those guys that can pitch with his
fastball against certain teams and be
fine but I don't think there's going to
be the case today he's going to have to
mix in his breaking ball and use his
change up our pitcher breakdown
presented by YouTube shorts you can spin
the ball and make those sliders hit hit
swing and Miss pitches from Strike the
ball and keep it in the yard you know
this team will hit the ball out of the
ballpark if you throw cookies up there
and he has to make those in-game
adjustments and throw a pitch up and up
in the end make that adjustment right
away you don't want to be too old
against this uh good very good hitting
White Sox team
going up against number two hitter
Andrew Vaughn
's another exciting player with the
White Sox who you know plays with his
hair on fire and brings a lot of energy
to his his ball team
big caught in the mess on that 94 that
overused to strike out Hernandez
bonna former third overall pick in 2019
when the golden spikes award at Cal in
college in 2018 rolls one to Short
-time goal Glover Anderson Simmons puts
him away
check out the total runs the line
courtesy of bet MGM nine and a half is
the number and that was changed a little
bit Lance Lynn Cy Young front runner in
the American League is going to be used
tomorrow in the Field of Dreams game for
the Chicago White Sox that means it's
over against Reynaldo Lopez what do you
think are you gonna get 10 runs today
I hope not because I mean it's gonna be
a very long game on and you're talking
to a picture Skype I want a pictures
duel I want the game to be two to one
two to two nothing
and a lot of strikeouts I mean I know
we've seen our share a strikeouts so far
in this season but I'm looking for a
pitchers duel I think you've got a shot
despite the fact that these two teams
can swing the bat I think both pitchers
on the mound if something to prove
over six foot nine as you mentioned and
you know you do it he does a really good
job of standing his delivery
controlling you know that long body
which is tough to do you see shorter
guys they're able to control their body
a lot better but it's a little bit more
difficult for guys who are tall and
lanky like he like he is and he's able
to repeat his delivery uh quite
frequently
Jose abreu's had some fun with him three
for seven a double a triple in Homer
last year's MVP fouls one back it's two
and two
that's a good point though about Ober is
the fact that it usually takes taller
pitchers more time to
refine their mechanics and it just
doesn't seem to be a problem for the 24
year old on the mound
that's pretty good stuff from Bailey
over a one two three first deep freezes
the former MVP and will head to the
bottom of the first inning here at
Target Field Live on YouTube
foreign
[Music]
deep down the line that ball is going to
be fair and a home run Polanco a
three-run ninth inning shot down the
right field line
to a swinging a blast into right field
and deep this one's back towards the
seats and gone Polacco does it again
one-nothing twins
three nothing and now Polanco
to the hole Garcia safe at first Polanco
beat out the hit and drove in another
run larnik scores from third base
stroke to the right field corner and
down for a hit Polanco rounding first
he'll dig for second Tucker's got a good
arm but Milan goes in with a first pitch
double in the sixth inning
palaco lifts at the left field Alvarez
is back looking up and it's gone to left
field
home run number 19 for Polanco and it's
a 4-2 ball game
and a high fly to right field way back
and gone number 20 for Polanco
[Music]
an impressive top of the first from
Bailey over and now his offense will
take over in the bottom of the first
inning led by Max Kepler and then Brent
Rooker in the two spot Jorge Polanco you
can see Distant Force in the lineup this
season Luis arrives 12 for 24 during an
eight game history he can really swing
the bat and make contact Miguel Sano
swinging the bat well lately Jake cave
Ryan Jeffers Trevor larnick and Andrew
Simmons to round out the starting nine
for Rocco baldelli's Minnesota Twins and
that lineup brought to you by YouTube
shorts and this is Reynaldo Lopez who
finds out he's going to be the man on
the mound instead of Lance Lynn today
there was a transactional move as well
Carlos Rodan hits the injured list with
shoulder fatigue and Tony larussa told
us just a little bit of soreness he'll
be back soon but that moves Lynn to
tomorrow to pitch in the Field of Dreams
game a very special really gem on the
calendar in Major League Baseball but
hey Lopez has a 159 era so far this
season eight appearances or make that
nine appearances one of them a start
against Minnesota little excuse me swing
from Max Kepler and they'll put him away
so a little pitcher breakdown presented
by YouTube shorts what is Reynaldo Lopez
all about he's had an up and down career
so far yeah he's had an up and down
career but compact delivery Larusso
talked about his delivery
um not getting uh too wild with his body
control in his body his fastball
location he tends to miss over the
middle if he can play with the corners
you have a success today then go For
Broke you know he's auditioning to be in
this rotation he's there right now
because of the injured list and see what
he can do he misses what a lot of
fastballs over the plate we'll use this
slider and just like you saw right there
and use that slider for strikeout mostly
out of the zone
Grant Rooker is trying to find himself
he's one for his last 20 and in an O2
hole
and Lopez didn't make the opening day
roster
[Music]
he had surgery on both corneas in early
may had a blurred vision issue I mean
that sounds like something that could
help a pitcher if you ask me I'll ask
you in a sec there's the strikeout on
three pitches going with the changeup
again Lopez picks up two quick outs
unless something that can help with all
athletes being able to see what you're
doing
I think just for any profession that's
gonna help the cause if you're having
Vision issues we've heard of some
players that have had LASIK surgery in
the past and then swung the bat better
but in this case for Lopez maybe it
helps him
sounds painful too cornea issue well it
was a real issue that he had had to have
both done
not just one he had both eyes uh
operated on and that's that's pretty
tough but you know he's he's done a
great job especially coming out of the
bullpen he's dropped uh one of his
pitches he's just a fastball slider guy
coming out of the bullpen but when he's
on the mount as a starter he has to use
his full repertoire and that includes
the curveball which kind of looks like
his sliders his slower version of it and
it's changed up sometimes
and he can dial it up he was a pretty
big Prospect when he came over in the
Adam Eaton deal of course the prize of
that deal ends up being Lucas giulito
Jack Swing did he go around no
forcing fastball is anywhere between 92
and 98 and some slight carry but his
Velo ticked up higher than that being
coming out of the bullpen for a limited
amount of time curveball 74-78 it's
changed up 80 to 90.
another check swing and he did not go
pretty wide variance on
CE ball velocity 92 to 98 usually you're
here you'll hear like 92 to 94 or 95 but
the fact that you can really switch it
up in terms of
what he brings to the table with the
heater
there's 94 up it's lofted shallow right
backing up Hernandez and he's got it
and that will retire this side so a one
two three first for Lopez we are
scoreless after one in Minneapolis
they are hard to catch particular with
Tim Anderson if he gets it done there is
victory at the end the 2-2 from the 24
year old Beau Burroughs from Texas says
Anderson pulls it to left and what a way
to start just like yesterday at Wrigley
for Tim Anderson the young man is
starting to get his rhythm it's this one
well to Center cave looks up and Jimenez
does it again how's this for a first
inning it is three nothing sucks in
Minnesota
and he tags this one to left down the
line into the corner and that ball is
gone a three-run shot foreign
feels good seeing giolito going like
this it's a night of Lucas gioleto and
it's been a good night so far the slider
has been very good spotted well whether
it's up down in or out the full arsenal
on display from Lucas giolito so nobody
aboard for Joan moncada
tags this one to center with cave back
and there's some hard contact
straightaway Center for Johan moncada
no score tap two at Target Field we're
always innovating here at YouTube with
our game so fans watching the MLB game
of the week Live on YouTube now have the
choice of listening to a number of
different feeds so you click the gear
icon in your player you can see it on
your screen and then you can choose
audio tracks so you can select primary
and hang out with us Scott Brown Latoya
Hawkins Lauren Gardner or take your pick
of the Home and Away Radio Calls all
audio is seamlessly integrated on your
favorite devices so you don't miss a
minute of the action they know what
they're doing trust me
sounds like a lot but it sure is very
simple it is
everything is super simple when I talk
to friends family how do you watch the
game today go to YouTube just type MLB
you're there you're here with us right
now Bailey Ober ready to work in inning
number two
first pitch swinging in on the hands and
that is going to drop
find some space in center field and Eloy
Jimenez
usually when he makes contact goes 100
plus off the bat and it goes a long way
and look at him jumping up and down look
what I found a little Seeing Eye Single
less respect you know outfielder
Jake caves out there he's playing on the
swing and usually he played deep when
eloy's hitting because
you know he will hit the ball out of the
ballpark and just drop that right over
Polanco's head in front of cave or lead
off single
until a jam shot you can see him looking
at his thumb like okay I'll take the hit
but my thumb doesn't feel well right now
in tight to Brian Goodwin yeah Jimenez
on Sunday and Monday put together two
home run five RBI performances first
player in franchise history to do it
very impressed with with Brian Goodwin
being able to watch him play and
you know come in and you know take
Louise Roberts spot in Centerfield and
hold it down like he didn't just go out
there and was just thrown in there
because they needed somebody you know he
went out there he took full advantage of
his opportunity and he's a pretty good
player man
we'll take you deep let me get his hits
there's still a couple bases and he can
really play the Outfield and I think
that was the plus that he really brought
to this team his ability to roam center
field he's gotten much better throughout
his career defensively he's seen over
four times homered against him six total
plate appearances he's walked a couple
times as well
again wants that one back Ober likes to
work vertically and you're seeing a lot
of high fastballs just a tick above the
Zone it's tempting
good four seam fastball that he uses
a lot of spin rate
a lot of extension too
that just missed
12 are very close as you can see through
the blocks they're not strikes but as a
pitcher you want those pitches
umpire wants to give them to you
he's not fooled by
Jeffers
ability to
frame it and make it look like a strike
full boat
popped up
and that's called by Jake Haven center
for the second out to make that the
first out
[Music]
now another outfielder who's performed
really well this season in limited time
you did miss about three months a couple
IL stints with a right hamstring strain
but when Adam Engel has been playing
he's been dangerous five for his last 13
seven home runs on the season and like I
said he hasn't played a ton but his
power has ticked up significantly this
year
you know I don't get a chance to see him
play against many other teams besides
the twins but he's always doing some
damage hit a home run the other night
straightaway center field
that's right back to over gets the added
second and quick flip to First and they
turn two and retire the side
perfectly executed by the big man on the
Mounds
pitch
the ball off into the back just a good
turn to Second and the first
foreign
Engel Hernandez LED off the inning where
the base hit he's still at first with
two gone this is hit hard in the air to
Center by Adam Engel with rap Snyder
[Applause]
this game is tied on
on swing from Adam Engel
1-1 Abreu hits one deep left Center
gone into the bullpen they go back to
back
and the Sox lead three to two
deal with a couple of ground out
the line
home run number six for La Tortuga got a
cutter didn't get didn't let it get
inside through his hands in through the
big end of the bat flipped it right in
the seats what a what a nice swing and a
nicest bat by Latoya last couple years
Alexander calling me was a pretty good
closer for the White Sox they decided
not to resign him Chopper to third a
rise in time
and the bullpen nearly perfect
bottom two no score LaTroy might not
love this as a former pitcher but I'm
all about it bat flips it's an art form
these days and you're looking at some of
the best in the biz who are able to do
it and I know you don't love these
little Troy but I know you're a big fan
of the YouTube poll questions so you're
gonna have to pick someone Tim Anderson
does it pretty well not in the lineup
today but you know he's energizing The
Dugout and he is a part of our list here
the most entertaining bat flipper in
baseball is we'll give you four picks
okunya tatis Bellinger or Anderson it's
on your screen right now brainer
no-brainer no-brainer I'm going with
Timmy a and and simply because he
started it back in what 2018
when it was still kind of frowned upon
and he didn't care no like you know I'm
going to celebrate every small victory
that I have on the baseball field and
I'm not one of those older guys who say
I don't like it no I walk it always
puzzled me why you couldn't celebrate
this game is hard enough why you can't
celebrate your small victories
and fans love it let's be real
especially this generation they love it
and as guys get to show their characters
guys get to be them I mean get to wear
what you want on your feet now whatever
whatever you want on your shoes you get
the bad flip you get to do all your
little dances whatever you're doing your
Euro Step after you hit a home run in
third base you get to do all of that and
it's good for the game it is good for
the game if it's good for the game
I love it
we have our live game commentary section
as well with YouTube creators let's hear
it from you
thoughts on some of the best bat
flippers
all right spells that one off
by the way Ashley Sanders part of the
live chat today says reylo has looked
filthy out of the pen in his short time
there this season anticipating a solid
start today so far so good
you know he's been throwing the ball
well
Russell
um commented about him being going back
down to trip away and working on his
delivery smoothing some things out her
eyes golf's wanting to Center angle
heading back and chasing it up against
the wall arise will hold up at second
with a lead off double in the second
inning
oh he's got him a breaking ball it
wasn't a bad pitch you can see that ball
he had to go down and get that ball off
the ground and was able to golf that
ball into right center field and Engel
was playing him
to the opposite field
can you talk about arise this is ability
to hit and worry you want him to hit as
many times as possible because he has he
finds a way to get his hits I don't care
if it's a lefty or right he's going to
find a way to get it to get his head to
you
that's why they've moved him down a bit
in the lineup cleanup hitter today
because they know with runners in
scoring position you're going to get a
good at bat you're likely going to get
contact and they've put Max Kepler up
there lately to try and help him find
things
here's Miguel Sano
Sano has been hovering around that 210
Mark he was down below the Mendoza Line
for a very long time so he's starting to
swing the bat a lot better and this team
needed him to do that after the Nelson
Cruz trade
crew is a big Mentor first you know
doesn't bite on 95 from Lopez it's in
the zone it's ball in the strike
getting some answers
from our YouTube creators Austin
classical always in there every week
saying Tim a because he started the way
bat flips are now tatis runner-up he's
with you boom
big cut and a miss from Sano on 96 down
the middle
you talk about that spread between his
fastball 92-98 you know when you see
that Scott is more so guys ramping it up
when you have Runners on base they're
ramping it up
especially in scoring position
and he's not stretched out yet so three
or four Innings they'll take from Lopez
today
slow roller right side only plays first
Hernandez makes it
and over to third goes arise let's bring
in Lauren Gardner okay so Lauren we're
going over the bat flips the poll
question first off I want your answer
and then also a little more please yeah
with LaTroy here I think it's ta-7 is he
kind of invented the modern day backflip
but I think if each league could have a
champion you got to go with tati's
Junior that guy is so fun to watch he
just plays the game with so much joy and
he's about as swaggy as it gets but you
know who does love a backflip and I say
this sarcastically of course ta Skipper
Tony larussa you know that the higher
racing eyebrows this off season how
would the old school approach combine
you know with the new school there let
the kids play there with Tim Anderson
and even admitted that he wasn't fully
on board with it this off season but the
two met up in spring training had some
amazing conversations and both really
respect one another and of course the
common Bond here is winning and larussa
was talking about ta-7s almost like
jordan-esque Competitive Edge and the
fact that he wants to win he just wants
to sit around and talk about winning
that he's a vocal leader in the
clubhouse so it seems like guys this Odd
Couple seems to be the perfect
combination I love that you're right the
common bond is just the essence of
winning and the mental aspect of it and
that was a good 10 minutes of our combo
this morning with Tony yeah I enjoyed
the kind of that part of the
conversation very much because he talked
about he compared
Timmy a to Michael Jordan his mentality
and his his burning desire to win and
you know going over Tony being a lot
older than most of the managers and of
taking on the responsibility of getting
this young team to the next level I'm
sure I wasn't the only person that
didn't know how it was going to go I I'm
sure I'm not alone but to see how it's
going you can understand like he's he
even said you know some things that he
sees he doesn't like but
don't get the comment every time on
everything you can't control everything
you gotta let the guys go out and be
free and enjoy themselves and they play
better when they're being free being
themselves and enjoying having fun
and look I mean he's the third oldest to
ever manage a game in major league
history Connie Mackle he takes the cake
he's seven years old he was still
managing baseball Jack mckeon's on the
list so is Dusty Baker matching the
Astros really well for a couple Seasons
now and Dusty's 72 years old Jay cave
check swing and he did not go
could hard slide it from Lopez
you see that bra breaking down
almost got J caved to swing at that
pitch
you see the slider it's not going
horizontal that ball is breaking
straight down
and he held up again
and see how tempting that high fastball
is to Major League hitters you know hard
for them to lay off of it
JK has really good numbers against Lopez
you got two home runs
five four eleven four fifty five had
some very good at bats against Lopez
face him a lot being an individual rival
plays off that one it's 3-2
Lopez has had a couple 3-2 counts
already
a JK's job right here is to get that guy
in from third base you see how close
Ryan Jeffers is
I mean he's about
three four steps in front of the circle
I think there's maybe so he can get a
real feel
in eye test for Lopez
cave goes in the air shallow I don't
know if it'll leave the infield it looks
like it will not Garcia makes the catch
and that won't get the job done
CJ cave a little
he's not happy with himself you have to
get that run in
when he's at third base with less than
two outs infield in
a little bit easier opportunity
for a base hit
so you had a slider looked like just
hovering over the middle of the plate
he understands he should have put a
better swing on that ball hit it harder
somewhere
so now it's Ryan jeffer's turn
although I felt like he was already at
the plate
he's close I'm telling you
yeah I think Jeffrey's probably the guy
on the team that hadn't had that many at
bats against Lopez all those other guys
have had plenty of batsman he's a
younger guy not many at bats he was
trying to get a a good eye on what he
was throwing up there before he was had
to go up there and face him
The Catcher in the seven spot
takes 95.
foreign
so it's Lopez today Lance Lynn tomorrow
night Field of Dreams game playing in
Iowa for the first time it's going to be
aesthetically pleasing to watch I'll
tell you that
and Lopez trying to crack the rotation
temporarily while rodon is on the
injured list I mean this is a tough
rotation to be a part of because we've
seen standout performances we've seen
consistency we've seen durability too I
mean Lance Lynn is in there every five
days Carlos rodana but until this point
had been in there and had been pitching
like a Scion candidate as well
swinging messed up Lucas giulito was
excellent earlier in this series and
we'll talk to Lucas very soon after the
bottom of the Third
when you have a strong rotation like
that
I mean and then a very good Bullpen when
you have
hey think about what they got
ta laugh you got Kimbrel uh kopeck's
been throwing the ball they just picked
up tempura
this guy Lopez looks pretty good now he
looks revitalized and after two we have
no score at Target Field
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got it
you win the inning he hasn't played a
lot of Rights what a nice catch to end
the inning
[Applause]
10 to the glopside
playing some sparkling defense on the
spin move that's Gold Glove kind of
stuff what a play by Tim let the home
Fly ball well hit
gone what'd you say about power that is
an enormous Insurance home run congrats
Cesar Hernandez his first White Sox home
run and it comes against their Crosstown
Rivals but that is a terrific addition
to this ball Club
so we don't miss
[Music]
Live on YouTube presented by YouTube
shorts watch and create videos on
YouTube try shorts in the YouTube app on
your phone Scott Ron LaTroy Hawkins
Lauren Gardner and many YouTube creators
joining us also the MLB channel White
Sox twins all adding to the unique
viewing experience you can check out
YouTube's live game commentary you can
view the live game commentary on your
computer your mobile device your smart
TV we'll keep an eye on the discussion
throughout the day we chat with them
they ask us questions and
I would like to Now call out questions
for Lucas giolito who joins us probably
10-15 minutes from now so we'll take
them now we'll load them up I'll ask the
questions from our YouTube creators
straight to Lucas in a few
could you just say 10 to 15 minutes from
now
jinx us like that I mean whatever you
want
how about six minutes from now six
minute inning would be impressive after
the third
thank you
other treats that we add to the YouTube
experience
miked up players stay tuned
this is I'm looking more looking forward
to that listening hearing the players
it's one of the best parts of the week
when we do these games
so you don't want to hear yourself you
want to hear the players yeah I like
that I like that they get to be
unfiltered
and you're hiked up I call it the
Futures game at the All-Star Game and
see how that turned out you were
bringing it
you can find that I'm sure on YouTube
some excellent sound bites from our guy
LaTroy Hawkins I had no clue you know
who brought it to my attention me I
think no my daughter she texted me
during the game she's like you need to
watch your mouth young man like
oh [ __ ]
the good stuff organic conversations
Jake Lamb facing a 2-2 count from Bailey
over he's been good so far it's just his
13th career start
tough to square up the heater from him
and the big difference also has been the
fact that over has picked up velocity
over the past couple Seasons he's a 12th
round selection at the College of
Charleston in 2017 not highly touted but
then once he hit the pro ranks he
immediately started dealing in 2019 he
had an 0-6-9 era across three levels of
the minor leagues with Big Time
strikeout numbers and low walks very
mature poised and I like his Pace too
that's why I said 10 15 minutes yeah he
gets uh he will get the ball and get
going but you're right he hadn't pitch
much
another slow roller and it's cleaned up
easily
okay so here's that miked up goodness
you're looking for LaTroy let's start
with Miguel Sano today he's got the mic
yeah but what what's your plan over
there when you hit him what are you
thinking you're trying to drive the ball
left field right field middle oh you're
looking for one pitch or water
[Applause]
okay
that's what I'm gonna try to do next
about
we heard Polacco just hard contact on
fastballs down the middle
that's the good stuff right there I mean
we're in mid-august
twins are having a tough year and Miguel
Sano is sitting there quizzing Jorge
Polanco who's been their best hitter now
without Nelson Cruz in the fold leori
Garcia goes after the first pitch he
likes it Opposite field base hit
how cool was that conversation though
he's not chilling going what's for
dinner no they're talking hitting and
most of the time when guys are on the
bench talking they're talking about
something that's that's in particular to
the game itself and you know he's
talking to the one of the hottest
hitters in the American League for the
last what about 40 games so I
and he told him he want the ball down
the middle
snow said guess what that's what I'm
gonna look forward to now we all know
you know Bailey over but he ain't pissed
a lot I mean he didn't throw more than
80 innings in one season in the minor
leagues not at all I mean
didn't pitch at all last year because of
the pandemic he wasn't at the team's uh
alternate site so we missed a complete
season and in 2019 he got the double A
so he hadn't pitched above double way
until this year
he's auditioning for a rotation spot
at this point in the season when you're
in a position that the twins are you you
know all the young guys are going out
there auditioning taking trying to take
advantage of an opportunity every single
day
Zach Collins trying to wipe away an over
17 skid
there he is getting ready for his
conversation
with you me and all the YouTube creators
with their questions
I'm just watching him and how he's able
he was able to
change his arm angle
back to where it was in high school and
I think he went for went to the tutelage
of his high school coach worked that
off-season and came back and he's been
absolutely incredible
since that
that revamp of his arm ankle it's been
pretty impressive and his ability to
throw those pitches in any count and
this change of me is probably the
biggest separator
Helen strikes out
third K of the day for Bailey Ober
just another fastball down the middle
slightly elevated
talked about him using being able to use
this poor scene fastball because of the
this Carry has and
like Colin swung where he thought the
ball was going to be you know for a guy
who doesn't have a lot of spin rate but
with him having high spin rate the ball
just never seems to take that dip stays
true
back to the top of the order and Cesar
Hernandez you know one of the best
starts of over his young career came
against this White Sox team on July 5th
five shutout Innings two hits a
career-high seven K's and an 8-5 win
I watched him last start on Friday
against Houston I mean that team makes
contact the Astros and he was
producing some swing and Miss with the
fastball this time it's contacting the
center fields and it's a knot for
Hernandez
first to Third and in there is Garcia
change up from
Bailey oberg not a bad pitch
Fernandez is just able to
to stay back on that ball and just
follow it to his Barrel you can see the
ball you know moving away from him he
got enough of it to punch that ball in
the center field
well that's the next step in the
progression for over Rocco baldelli told
us
just learning how to spin the baseball a
little bit better and in different ways
and utilize his secondary pitches and
tighten them up because the fastball has
played up so well
so we talk about
getting Runners the third base will
lasted two outs very good teams find a
way to get that runner from third base
in
we also talked about obers change up not
being one of his better pitches you're
not going to see it a lot and his last
start
that was one of the pitches that he had
some trouble with leaving it elevated
if he can figure out a way to get that
ball down and let it play that way
it could be a usable pitch for them
that's a great pitch right there 94 up
and in
here's Vaughn two outs with Runners and
scoring positions two for 38. that's
surprising
I think that number is going to start to
turn around for him he's looked better
as the season has gone on but he's
always a threat to hit the ball out of
the ballpark it's 13 home runs so far
but as you can see the Twins game plan
against bonus off the pitch of me to tie
those hands up
try to stay away from the middle of the
plate or anything middle away
you get the ball close to them as
possible
see if they can get some swinging misses
like you have the first two fastballs
got him
fishing for some high cheese Bailey over
wiggles out of it Lucas giolito is going
to join us in just a moment here no
score mid three
[Applause]
and a high-fly left field off the bat of
Garber he has touched off a three-run
home run with two out Garber puts the
twins in front the 2-2 is swinging to
drive into right field and deep down the
line that ball is going to be fair and a
home run a three-run ninth inning shot
down the right field line
and he makes the catch ER with a diving
catch near the foul line
and a high fly to right field way back
and gone and the twins break it open
home runs 19 and 20 today for Polanco
number 20 a big one with a couple of men
aboard
bare-handed and so now threw him out
what a play by Miguel sonoda and the
game it was do or die for Sano he came
charging in grabs it with that big right
hand and throws a bullet right on the
money to Garver at first base what a
terrific play
[Applause]
[Music]
last of the third White Sox and twins no
score yet nice pitching performances so
far today from Lopez and Ober and we
answer our first poll question of the
day Live on YouTube most entertaining
bat flipper in baseball hey look at
Fernando tatis Jr win this thing despite
the fact that we have probably a heavy
dosage of White Sox fans watching right
now and they did chime in they weighed
in heavily Anderson picks up 34 of the
pie I mean those two were definitely
receiving the most buzz in the live game
commentary section as well so let's get
the answer to that question from our
friend Lucas giolito who joins us for
this half inning it's the YouTube shorts
interview Lucas how you doing and help
us out here what's going on how's it
going guys what's up Luke how are you
I'm good just chilling today early game
good morning how much coffee
um I had a couple uh a couple coffee
beverages this morning had a nice waffle
hot or cold coffee I prefer cold coffee
you look like a cold coffee guy and
hopefully a hot waffle yes
eight nine and one do up for the twins
larnik Simmons and Kepler Reynaldo Lopez
getting the spot start today all right
first off before we get into everything
else Lucas we need your answer to the
poll question that we just asked most
entertaining bat flipper tatis one
Anderson finished second that's your
only teammate on the list and yeah maybe
some gum after the waffle too but tell
Billy Hamilton hello yeah we got the we
got the like clown Corner over here
that's where we're at so I don't I don't
usually hang out back on this side too
much I like to pop in and out but you
guys have me over here for the interview
so they might be doing stuff the whole
time
um I mean this is the best bat flipper
right here I don't know if the camera
can pick him up hey there he is there we
go I don't care what the poll says I
mean this guy he's done bad spikes he's
thrown in the air he's done it all
look that's what I said I said he's the
guy who originally started it and made
it cool again he started and didn't care
what the other teams yeah yeah 100 no
disrespect to tatties uh super exciting
player I haven't had the chance to play
against him yet but I think Timmy is the
king of the bat flip as of right now and
then we even got a goodie hopping on
that wagon as well I don't know if you
guys saw uh his last walk-off Homer he
he tossed it about 25 feet in the air
after well you get a walk off you you
can do whatever whatever it is that your
body tells you to do yeah just look out
because if it's going that high it's
coming down
Lucas Julieta with us as
Trevor larnick Works a walk and now a
check over to First how do you think
Reynaldo Lopez looked so far today I
mean he's put together a really quietly
nice season since he's been up here
again yeah yeah I've known lopi for a
long time we came up together in the
Nationals organization
and
these guys man uh you're true so yeah no
we're good we we came up together uh
same level like all the way from Rookie
ball a ball double A and lopi was always
better than me like super nasty stuff up
to 100 uh he had a really good curveball
really good change up and then you know
the last couple years a couple hardships
I mean stuff that we all go through as
baseball players and uh this year he
made a couple mechanical adjustments uh
at the beginning around spring training
time working with our pitching coach
and a little bit of an adjustment period
with those and now he's up up here doing
his thing uh he's been fantastic since
getting called done I kind of see him
like a man on a mission uh really just
proving uh how good of a pitcher he is
top to bottom I mean he's commanding the
ball his velocity is there the life on
all of his pitches so yeah it's a good
one so far yeah he's giving up just one
hit so far today and Simmons did not go
around according to last Diaz first base
up hanging out with Lucas giolito right
now I'm going to mix in some questions
from the YouTube creators Austin klashco
leads us off here he says Hey Lucas how
strange was it to throw a no-hitter with
no crowd behind it when did you realize
what you were doing how did you keep
yourself locked in
it was just one of those there we go
there it is Soft Stuff Strikes Out
Simmons one away
so it was one of those uh like special
nights as a athlete that you know comes
every once in a while where it was like
I had that Peak Performance state from
the get-go and I just did everything in
my power to stay focused and locked in
and not let go of that and so I was able
to uh you know have a really really
great night obviously a lot of credit
goes to my teammates as well a no-hitter
you have to be very lucky uh it's not
it's not ever like oh 100 the pitcher
just did his thing so there's just a
very very special night I would have
loved to have our White Sox home crowd
there that's the one thing the one thing
about it that gets me is you know we did
do it in front of the empty Stadium but
I felt a lot of love from our fans after
on social media and things like that so
essentially you're saying it didn't
matter because you were locked in yeah
yeah you were locked in you wouldn't
have noticed them anyway because you're
locked in yeah 2020 was a bit weird in
the beginning for all of us uh that
first series those first couple series
of the year in 2020 with no fans at all
just kind of getting used to like
finding other ways to get that
adrenaline you know everybody's
different for me I really really
appreciate a nice pack stadium so that
was an adjustment period but by that
point in the season we were all kind of
used to it and just was part of it
this is Max Kepler
larnik on first Lopez deals and that's a
bit down okay next question from
quashtag hey Lucas went on the road
where's your favorite place to pitch
Minnesota
[Music]
I'd really like to pitch inside uh so
you know Dome stadiums like one of my
favorites is for sure Houston even
though it's a hitters park I just like
the five in there and I like the air
conditioning obviously
I like Tampa as well
um not so much for the stadium but just
like having that like closed space you
don't have to worry about wind you don't
have to worry about the Sun or anything
like that it's like very controlled and
hitters often don't love hitting down at
the Trap just ask Willie Thomas he's
been doing pretty well since he moved on
Kepler thought about
and it's a strike
borderline pitch but a very good pitch
from Lopez good slider
caught enough with a plate
you have that down below the line
I gotta own the line
Manny Gonzalez did a good job on that
pitch stand with it and not being fooled
by The Catcher And just calling the
strike a strike love that
coming from a pitcher Lucas oh yeah
hey you can tell Billy Hamilton if you
want to get on we probably can find him
some headsets
yeah they're one Billy they're wondering
if you wanted to get on here you keep
looking over at me
tell him he looks bored
payoff coming to Max Kepler
first a check and they got oh yeah
that's the best
how good does that feel Oh I thought I
would never pick a guy off
and I've done it twice this year don't
know how low
wow I mean got him easy it's not even
close
I love that we have the mic close to
Hamilton and ta too he's the best hey
that's the best motivation let me mix in
a few more
we love to support each other over here
on the South Side well Lucas you know
it's a lot easier to pick guys off now
because umpires just refuse to call a
balk
and you know a lot of pitchers have that
that knee jerk that front knee jerks
yeah yeah the bulk move so
I'm not surprised you're picking guys
off now because you use it yeah
I found a certain thing I can do that
kind of helps I don't want to talk about
them good I understand I understand tell
us after your playing days keep it a
secret yeah yeah absolutely exactly and
I brought that up because I looked at
Lopez front knee and that's how I
Collapse and that's what larnik is
looking at and that's why he was so far
and it wasn't close at first base
I remember the likes of the day the Ken
Kaiser and Meriwether and all those guys
they bought Bach Bach
I love a good pickoff who doesn't Brent
Rooker is the number two later he's over
one so far today
uh you're gonna need a new bat sir while
he's doing that MLB's channel is asking
a question Lucas are you going into the
corn tomorrow at all are you excited for
the Field of Dreams game oh yeah I am
pumped I'm pumped to not be pitching in
it because I'm going to be there like a
fan uh you know I like the movie I
haven't seen it in a while but I do like
the movie I don't know if Kevin Costner
is going to be there if he's there it'd
be cool to meet him uh and then I saw
some of the uh some pictures of the corn
maze and everything I think that we're
gonna have a group of guys go and try
and do the corn maze you know maybe uh
put a little wager on who's fastest
let's see
and I think the maze is shaped like the
MLB logo I believe I have that right yes
yeah so if that helps you at all
during your Excursion there I want you
to win
against Billy Hamilton don't run against
Billy Hamilton you might leave lose
trips
just Mr Rucker the ball in a strike okay
we're showing it I know you might not be
able to see it Lucas but the world is
watching now on YouTube and that
includes the maze
MLB logo maze wow that ballpark looks
insane and also I heard the dimensions
are pretty tight Lucas so again maybe
not the worst thing hey not that you
could you You're great with home run
prevention but you know what I'm saying
I I'm not great with home run prevention
so yeah that's another reason that I
failed to mention a second ago is to you
know I'm happy that we got a big daddy
land so he's gonna be on the mound he's
our guy and uh hopefully we get a win
there but at the same time just like
really enjoy the experience I've been
jealous of the other teams over the last
few years they got to like go out and do
like the Little League World Series
games in Japan and England so this
should be fun I agree this was fun we
did a little bit of everything you're
off the hook get out of that danger zone
with those guys attacking you thanks
again good to talk to you okay yeah yeah
thank you
Lucas giolito hanging out with us for
this half inning on YouTube wow Ronaldo
Lopez avoided any damage after three
still no score
[Music]
is palpitating
[Music]
Fernando cleared everybody out of the
way everybody out I'll take care of this
and he did after all said and done the
Fernando tattoos Jr taking charge
everybody scatters apart for the out
and launches one to deep left center
field Trace Pereira is on the board with
his first big league Homer
those guys are reading check it out
Trey's reading now they're gonna mob and
watch let's see how long they stick with
it
well this is a long silent treatment
usually they're already celebrating by
now look at
it
I started trying to get close and then
once I got a little closer I realized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we climb into the fourth inning here in
Minneapolis and first have a look at
some of the notable Al trade deadline
Acquisitions the trade deadline was wild
Nelson Cruz leaves the twins goes to the
Rays Anthony Rizzo is a Yankee burritos
from Minnesota to Toronto in the lab and
for next year as well and Craig Kimbrel
shows up across town
were you shocked at that one more than
the rest
um I just
it kind of shocked me that they were to
pull that off but I'm gonna have to go
with with Craig Kimbrel for the biggest
impact yes there's impact off the bat of
Jose Abreu but there's room there in
Center for JK to run it down for the
first out so you think that'll be the
biggest deal especially come playoff
time yes it will be because their
Bullpen was 16th in Major League
Baseball with a 408 and he just
solidifies a a spot in that Bullpen
where they probably had a little issue
at
and he's to add another closer how many
teams have two closers in there two
All-Star closers in their Bullpen not
many and they have Hendricks and
Kimbrough and that's the that's the
eighth inning the ninth inning soda
and their starters are going six Innings
a piece sometimes more so they only they
only have to cover from maybe three outs
what
we don't know the team goes where the
pitching's open in the in the playoffs
you have to have a solid Bullpen they
are built for something special there's
no doubt
Bailey over matching up against deloy
Jimenez right now
by the way that poll question is live
answers please it's an easy click or a
press
and we'll pay it off later
kopeck copex is one of those guys who he
was a starter and might get a chance to
start again but he's been really good
coming out of the bullpen with that 98
miles an hour Sinker that he throws
this guy's pretty good too Garrett
crochet from the left side brings big
stuff
smack
and a base hit his second of the day
you mentioned kopeck
there's a new moniker for this Trio and
the back end of the bullpen it's the
ponytail gang
and it's easy to know why they're called
back
see you a little
ponytail action on the back end for each
of them and look at the Cheese
97.97 close to 98 for Hendricks on the
average fastball velocity their
strikeout machines
you add it all up and hey you're in
trouble if you face the White Sox in
October it's a three-headed monster
three-headed three-headed ponytail game
coming at you
Mata queso
the ponytail does not hold back the
velocity
confirmed aerodynamic might help
Goodwin has Jimenez on First with one
out here in the fourth
here's a strike that's where Ober likes
to work
the White Sox have three hits and two of
those hits
by Eloy Jimenez
pitch number 50 of the day from over
all speed strike and he's been hanging
around the 60-ish pitch count range and
many of his outings lately
I think they'll let him go up to
the 80 range
if they're somewhat stress-free but
we'll see
there's no hard limit on his pitch count
it's just the fact that they want to be
cautious with him because as you
mentioned he hasn't pitched much the
last few seasons he's dealt with a few
injuries but also last year for example
he's not a big Leaguer and he wasn't at
the alternate site so he really wasn't
pitching in competitive action no not at
all he's lost he lost some valuable time
you know I'm sure in his mind but being
able to make it to the major leagues The
Following season but he's never thrown
more than 80 innings in the season one
hop that's lined up nicely oh and a nice
catch and pirouette over to first though
not in time Goodwin beat that throw so
the fielder's choice of racist Jimenez
look at the twins shifted right there
ground ball to second baseman Jorge
Polanco and kind of threw that ball
chest to the glove side of Arias he had
to gather himself before he can make the
throw the first base
but when you plan A Shift You know guys
are taking balls from different angles
they having to throw the ball from
different angles have a lot more ground
to cover to get to the bag it causes
some kind of you know gets you know the
defense out of sync just a little bit
that's a double play on about what half
the Batters in the league
foreign
right side
and there it is Polacco makes the play
hitting over
Bailey Ober Works around a base hit both
pitchers like I said making a name for
themselves so far this afternoon mid
four still nothing
as long as Lucas giolito can remember
I've always had animals in the house
he's been surrounded by pets I had fish
I had a bearded dragon at one point same
for his now wife Ari who developed such
a love for Animals she'll soon be
finishing up vet school at UC Davis I
mean it's been a fantastic experience uh
not only for Ari but for myself as well
one of the perks has been Ari's work
with the orphan kitten project a
student-run non-profit that's been
rescuing kittens since 1988. here he is
there's Lionel Lionel is one of The
giolito's Fosters they also have a dog
who's apparently become a pretty good
traveler so with the help of sports
apparel brand Roto Ware giolito is now
selling shirts to raise money for the
orphan kitten project I have a pretty
big platform that's growing now it's
like am I gonna do something with this
or am I just gonna like
play baseball and and you know get a
bunch of money and then kind of
disappear that's not really what I'm
interested in
[Music]
we're in the home fourth with no score
in Minneapolis and it's time for our
creator Spotlight each week this season
we'll focus on a YouTube content creator
featured in our live game commentary
section and today we shine on Andy Rulo
love the hair too look at him go all out
and over 40 000 subscribers over 2
million views and his YouTube Creator
career MLB gaming videos behind the
scenes Vlogs Dodger films softball games
he loves the Mariners and he's hanging
out with us in the live chat say hello
to us please Andy at some point and
we'll include a comment or a question
during the broadcast
new man on the mound it's Garrett
crochet who takes over for Reynaldo
Lopez who was excellent during his time
on the mound in a spot start this
afternoon crochet 22 years old era south
of three on the season mostly features a
four-seamer and a slider
we'll crochet last pitch on Monday here
against the twins
he can dial it up
I remember his debut last year in
September hit 101.5 on the radar gun
makes me shake my head wow
fastball could be anywhere between 94
and 100 got a slight cut but some good
carry he throws a slider
81 to 91 miles an hour
slurvy but you know big sweeping slider
throwing it harder lately than he did
when he first came into the league last
year
it's a good mix
11th overall pick in 2020 added the
University of Tennessee
he's missed on his first three
Tennessee is in what conference
no they're not an SEC yeah and SEC okay
he went from the SEC to the big leagues
he went from the yeah don't ask him
about the minor leagues the big leagues
of of college sports to the big leagues
of amazing professional baseball I love
it 3-1 is smacked in the air and it's
hanging up there for Goodwin circling
around and finding it
one away
so after Polanco is retired her eyes
coming up and this copyrighted telecast
is presented by authority of the office
of the commissioner of baseball and may
not be reproduced or re-transmitted in
any form in the accounts and
descriptions of this game may not be
disseminated without Express written
consent
[Music]
arise doubled back in the second
and he'll watch 95 down Broadway that
could have been a changeup the 95.
the changeup gets up to the 92-93 range
which is absurd
look at his left hand hitters he loves
to use his fastball slider mix
two shot strikes he's gonna go for the
punch out most times with the slaughter
as much as I was bummed that we weren't
getting a Lance Lynn start today Lopez
was fantastic and then
this Bullpen can bring it LaTroy and I'm
sure you'll appreciate that
thing is we're going to see their
Bullpen out there today because of
Lopez not being built up to go five plus
Innings so we're gonna get a chance to
see at least four of their their Bullpen
arms
last four games have gone well for the
relief pitching
no runs 11 Innings 19ks to two walks
and there's another
that brings us to Miguel cenault who is
miked up today
hey I want to ask you you never watched
my movie better my movie Bellator your
movie yeah documentary you got a movie
yeah Bobby
yeah Las Vegas baby
I have a monkey a couple years ago they
call it Mr Wilson
first base conversations are epic
especially with that guy wow he's got
the lines
and that's true by the way there is a
documentary on you also know I think
correct me if I'm wrong 16 year old yeah
when he was 16 and then I think they're
putting together a sequel to that
are you serious I think so I'll have to
double check that A lot's changed since
he was 16.
I mean clearly he's good in front of the
camera
takes big hacks
three true outcome player a lot of walks
strikeouts homers
yeah he's taking a lot more walks this
last year
but you know he loves to swing at that
high fastball
he's much better on the pitches that are
down
no go
it's one and two
there you go this is
1900 since we're keeping track here
three true outcome percentage
Homer walk strikeout
chances are one of those results is
happening let's see
Russell branyan
sure you faced him oh yeah he can hit
the ball a mile also big strong guy
Chris Carter
I'm sure you face Jack kusts too number
two on that list no I don't I don't
remember possibly 21 season the mother
fixed a guy that was the head of that
list also
oh crochet wanted that one
that was a change up from crochet and
this change up going up there at 92
miles an hour it's like some some guy's
fastball
not a bad pitch
just not a good enough pitch for to get
a swing from Miguel to know statcast
liked it but that's okay crochet pulls
it off on the next pitch
sits down the side in order including
two punch outs it's the White Sox
bullpen taking over in the fourth as we
hit the fifth still scoreless
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've talked about his healing skills
that was remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what they came for
[Applause]
foreign
new this season in the MLB game of the
week Live on YouTube series
it is the YouTube player of the game
you're gonna help us out later mobile
device computer you'll click the poll
who's going to receive the trophy they
love the trophy and also it helps us
decide who we're talking to post game
stay tuned for the player of the game
polling options later in the show here's
our latest poll results Al trade
deadline acquisition app the biggest
impact this season and the crowd thinks
Craig Kimbrel is going to take that over
Anthony Rizzo in second place with 30 of
the vote and then there's Brios and
Nelson Cruz
I saw a fist bump from LaTroy Hawkins
that's right
you helped influence the crowd this time
LaTroy good job
it's Jake Lamb liori Garcia and Zach
Collins seven eight and nine do up
Bailey Ober still working here in the
fifth and picks up two quick strikes and
let's send it down to Lauren yeah Scotty
of course LaTroy is an influencer we're
talking about Boomstick being one of
those big Acquisitions at the deadline
try finding out that you were part of
the trade while you're sitting in
quarantine in Tokyo right before the
Olympics that's exactly what happened
with Joe Ryan who ended up being a
silver medalist as we know so he found
out that he was part of it while he's
eating breakfast over in Japan but he's
had a really positive attitude about all
of it despite the shock saying it's just
an honor to be traded for such a good
player in Nelson Cruz and guys if you
take a look at what he's done in the
past he could be a big part of this
twins rebuild in AAA Durham he was four
and three with the 363 era in his last
full season in the miners which was 2019
he was nine and four with a 196 era and
if this tells you anything about the guy
his nickname is Ace
I mean it doesn't get better than Ace
that's a big name to live up to that is
that's true that's a lot of action too
you're out there in Japan trying to win
a medal then you find out you're
switching teams
like hold up let me uh let me pick up a
metal first then I'll come back to minor
league Action Now joining a new
organization twins are excited to have
him
pulling back on the bunt is Garcia after
the base hit for Jake Lamb yes not an
error
it was a huge pickup for the for Nelson
Cruz
Joe Ryan
you know we talk about you know when I
was here when Nelson was traded and it
was just a sad day but we kind of knew
it was coming but it was still prepare
yourself for it he was you know having
Joe Ryan's you know looking at his
numbers and you know looking at his his
uh pitch usage
really good
hitter air LaTroy
I'm going to give him an error no I'll
give him a hit on that ball kind of came
up on him and with the shift he's taking
the ball from shortstop he's a second
baseman slash third baseman
it's 105 miles an hour off the bat too
crushed
yeah when you you know what our Scouts
like the most about Joe Ryan was his
fastball 80 89 to 94.
but when it's carried about it talk
about how you know how quickly the ball
gets on you on hitters and it looks a
lot lively livelier than that a really
good change up
that should be playable angilton Simmons
has it
and then the heads up to fired back into
the infield so that lamb cannot move to
Second wow
perfect throw from his hind part it's a
second base and he's such an instinctual
player I mean you know a lot of times
you get his defense gets overlooked
because of the light back but you know
his baseball IQ and his ability look at
the ground he covers because he was he
was playing behind behind second base
and he he covered a lot of ground to
make this play
and we had to ignore it all
to make sure that that Runner didn't tag
up from first base
right hands great feet
um baseball IQ is off the charts I mean
he had a play last week where the ground
ball man was a second base it was oh
tiny was a second base Brown ball to him
ohtani leaks off a second base he throws
the ball to Polanco at second base to
get Shoei back Polanco turns and throws
the ball to Sono well Sano was running
from the bag from his position to the
bag to get ready to take the throw from
from Simmons and it was coming from
Polanco's second base he completely
missed it
sometimes you're too fancy right right
he's like that great point guard who
making plays that everybody else in the
passes that people can't catch yeah it's
the perfect behind the back but you
weren't ready for it the guy wasn't
there right
he's next level that was great 121 feet
to cover for Simmons and he came up with
the baseball and arrives ducked away
from it just in time they're still
talking about it right now
that was what impressed me too after all
of that right you make the catch
you avoid the Coalition for the most
part immediately in his brain he's like
I gotta make sure I get this ball to
second base Jake Lamb is not moving up a
base on me
you know when I look at them and think
about some of the greatest shortstops
that I saw played in my time in like
this scale like
didn't have the greatest arm but he
always got the ball back
you always understood his internal clock
was always right
look at him he's like her eyes move out
of the way dude I gotta throw it back to
sec
two and one on Collins
now three and one
Goldberg's done a great job of
not walking guys
and getting towards the bottom of this
line he's at the bottom of this lineup
and we want guys on base when when the
Big Bopper started to come up
I just showed you that's above average
statcast helps us out metric to help
Define your defensive efficiency and
obviously Angela Simmons is top five on
that list
the front saved is a popular stat
s above average is competitive with that
stat really helps to sum up your season
on defense ball four
okay statcast powered by Google Cloud
help us out take us back to what
Angleton Simmons just did
look at him go see where he started at
it's a much easier play for the
shortstop if he's playing straightaway
shortstop but he started right behind
second base
and caught that ball behind third base
and foul territory
now this is the funniest thing to see
Wes Johnson
who's vertically challenged not that
tall of a guy standing next to Bailey
oberg on on the mound and Bailey told me
this person when Wes comes out to talk
to him he tries to walk to the back of
the mountain so he can look at him eye
to eye and that's exactly what he's
doing now he's at the back of the
mountain he's standing up now
that's respect I like that that's really
cool
and while we have a set Google cloud is
helping to power statcast with massive
amounts of data points to reveal new
insights taking you deeper into the game
than ever before Google cloud is the
official Cloud technology of Major
League Baseball and thank you statcast
for helping us out with that last play
and thank you Bailey Ober for showing
respect to your pitching coach as a roof
I'm sure he appreciates that
it's the third time around the lineup
for Bailey oberg
if he can get a few more outs
it's a good test for him
Cesar Hernandez singled last time up
struck out first time around
I mentioned Ober looked pretty good
I test wise in his last start against
the Astros he did give up two home runs
although I can say with confidence both
of them were Minute Maid Park shots
you know just over the wall short
porches out there they would not have
left the yard here
we have not seen much lab contact from a
team that does plenty of it so what was
the probability of those balls being out
in other ballparks low very low yes
I love that stack cast by the way
well you can do an overlay of the
ballparks to see if it would have left
the yard in other locations and that's
what I did and he was okay where was
that
that was not a strike flip it elevated
but he's throwing some other ones that
were closer and you can see the White
Sox dug out chirping a little bit
to Manny Gonzalez so do you go right
back there
and I would he's giving that pitch you
might as well go where he's giving
giving the strikes
that was one of the better change-ups
over his throne you see that ball was at
the knees
a good spot not elevated like the
previous event he threw this Caesar
Hernandez and the elevated change that
he was able to hit that ball that's in
the field that ball right there nothing
he can do with it but roll over or just
fouled It Off
Collins on first lamb on second a ball
and two strikes on lead off man Cesar
Hernandez
got him
fifth strikeout this afternoon for
Bailey Ober got a couple fastballs
elevated for the strikeout
LG what else can you tell us about this
tall Gentleman on the mound today yeah
he
can tell you what the weather is like up
there but he was known as a soft tosser
until he put some work into his
mechanics this past off season so during
his downtime in 2020 as well so he added
a few ticks to his Velo getting up to 91
to 94 as we saw there and we talked to
rock about Delhi about it you know I
said hey did you do anything
specifically to get him you know to
increase his Velo and he said I think
just some of the adrenaline being you
know pitching in the big leagues I think
could absolutely do it we talk about the
pitch count Kevin Dillon our amazing
researcher gave me this nugget here he
reached a high of 93 on July 5th against
the Chicago White Sox but every other
outing it's been 85 or below
wow Vaughn is tied up a bit there it's
nothing in two so clearly he's playing
up to competition
the Drone is Flowing for him
he's understanding his opportunity this
year make it start
taking advantage of it
and I love the fact we like to see young
pictures
when they're when the catches that we're
going in
they're missing in not over the plate
you know you can see he's pigeon very
tough and all the fastballs in have been
up and in and that one's just a little
closer to his body but he's getting a
lot of swings from Vine because he looks
like he can hit that ball the closer it
is to his body
he's upstairs
barely over picking up another punch out
six on the day he strands two Runners
here in the fifth as we're still looking
for offense into Twin Cities
foreign
[Music]
from Birmingham Wilson Alvarez on the
hill
grab some bits so Wilson Alvarez punches
out to the side here in the first two
outs bases empty and the pitch Melvin
swings and misses and down he goes
and the Orioles here in the fourth
inning looking for their first base hit
good jump I think it makes the catch now
the one nothing offering Kafka is there
to make the grab for the final up no two
pitch yes grab some bench that'll do it
let's head into right field new son yeah
so Deacon makes the catch and that'll
retire the size
there's a Looper Lance Johnson coming oh
[Music]
what a practice
[Applause]
Major League appearance has just thrown
a no-hitter
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Minneapolis today Iowa tomorrow for the
White Sox and these are the classic
units that they'll be sporting for the
Field of Dreams game against the New
York Yankees that's a good look that's a
fitting look for what we're about to see
in tomorrow's contest
I'm all for the old school uniforms
the different color uniforms I really
like they're all black uniforms they
have those were sick those are nice
no logo on the cap just nice and clean
and get ready for the first major league
baseball game in Iowa where the Yankees
and the White Sox will Clash for the MLB
at Field of Dreams presented by Geico
catch all the action Thursday that's
tomorrow August 13th six o'clock Eastern
time on Fox
everyone is fired up for that on the
White Sox side we've been chatting with
them about it this morning leading up to
game time
trying to not look too far ahead as they
finish up a season series against the
twins this afternoon
JK with a bunt in the air easy loved by
Andrew Vaughn
one gone
betray you and I are going our separate
ways to continue to work but Lauren
Gardner will follow the Chicago White
Sox over to Iowa looking forward to that
one Arch algae I am Scotty I don't know
how I drew the long straw in this one
but somehow I'm hopping in a car after
this game and driving directly down to
Dyersville Iowa obviously home of the
Field of Dreams game it was really fun
listening to Liam Hendricks on Monday
and the presser for this hosted by Adnan
Burke with MLB Network and he said you
know he was part of the Japan series
with the A's it was such an incredible
experience and of course he saw the
movie as a kid in Australia because he
said anything with Kevin Costner was
going to be on their television sets but
that he didn't fully understand the
concept so he just said he saw a bunch
of ghosts running around but then of
course he's excited for the opportunity
to play in the first major league game
in the state of Iowa he just hopes he
doesn't will paraphrase and say stink
and uh give up the first major league
Homer in that state and he's looking
forward to doing the corn maze just like
Lucas giulio said but this guy is so
pumped to be part of history and guys I
can't tell you how excited I am I mean I
didn't bring my glove I don't know how I
forgot so I'm gonna have to borrow
someone's Lefty glove to have a catch
gotta have a catch out there you've got
to work that corn maze too I know you'll
be into that I'll get lost I might need
someone I might need to drop a pin and
have someone come in and find me will it
work out there I don't know
sure but I'll do it I'm in we'll help
you from afar we'll be watching for sure
it's going to be awesome
I'm excited I can honestly say I hadn't
seen the movie fill the dreams and
in decades but
Major League Baseball taking the game
there is awesome that is awesome
it's a great idea it's going to look
really good on TV Ryan Jeffers down on
strikes
the hard fastball elevated and
hitters cannot lay off those High
fastballs
Trevor larnick
off speed strike one
Garrett crochet is not fun to face
oh he's tough on lefties tough on
righties but I'm sure it's a very
uncomfortable wear bath for our left
hand hitters
he doesn't usually go more than an
inning but
is that 25 pitches
and the White Sox hope for one more
batter
I mean we may see The Gauntlet today oh
we will kopeck Kimbrell
Hendrix
fastball up and in on Trevor Lonnie
let's try lucky got a piece of this bat
and trying to get out of the way
[Applause]
any daddy avoided
Manny Gonzalez took a hit
other way and that's gonna drop and
Jimenez does keep it in front of him
it's a two out single for Trevor larney
foreign
hitter he hit his way and hit it well
into minor leagues and you know when he
got to the bigleys he's been pulling the
ball alive so to see him and go to take
that ball to left field even though it
is awful hard throwing left hand pitcher
that's a good sign because he hadn't had
any problems hitting spraying the ball
all over the field and once he got to
the major leagues he's been as you can
see the way they played him Deadpool and
he's hadn't been happy with himself
about that so that's a good sign to see
him hitting the ball at opposite field
he's got a good swing
pretty from the left side former first
round pick 20th overall in 2018 he's 24
years old
the opportunity to be a very good hitter
in the major leagues he and Alex kirloff
two left-hand High prospects with the
twins
great about the ball skills here a lot
that season ending wrist surgery last
month
Simmons was a strikeout victim in the
third
that's in there
[Music]
no high fastball they was able to clip
the top of the zone
who played Manny Gonzalez's
freely call in the higher pitch
as opposed to the balls
east and west
Jose Ruiz warming up
[Music]
foreign
ball for Simmons
some close pitches and
Simmons
didn't bite it close pitches even the
strike that was caught at the top of the
zone was able to work yourself up
a one-out walk
a two out walk
makes sense though to try and stretch
out crochet to be a two-ending guy come
play off time why not I mean he's
certainly capable of doing it he's been
a starter before and he pitches
nasty stuff that we've seen on display
today and all season they're trying to
get a little more out of him
White Sox pigeon coach Ethan Katz just
giving him a breather and two outs let's
focus on the hitter
Max Kepler and he was back in the dug
house
and try to score some runs
but I like I like crochet's delivery I
like his leg kick
the um the deception that he creates
with a little hesitation after he kicks
his leg up it's kind of like he stalls
out a little bit and then exposed to the
plate
a lot of deception with a lot of queso
coming by yeah he's got the deception
and the stuff that's a powerful
combination
Kepler doesn't go after the first pitch
I feel bad for Lefty hitters
put it that way
they've been trying to get Kepler going
in the lead off spot
a crochet's leg kick
that one right there is not as big as
the normal one that's more of a load and
go slight slide step you use that more
when you have guys on base and a lot of
times if you use it when nobody's on
base it's to disrupt the hitter's timing
because they're looking for that big leg
kick
larnac and Simmons on board
it's 3-0
runners in scoring position not doing a
ton a buck 56 no long balls eight RBIs
you know what they call that Scott huh
domination
locking things down when you need to
not just against this team the entire
world of baseball
he finds the zone
and then he Gonzalez we calling it high
pitch and Coach he was able to clip the
high inside fastball
try to get back somewhat get back in
account
good hitters count right here for Kepler
and get them some over the middle of the
plate hit something hard somewhere do
some damage
most of that damage comes against
pitchers you use their right hand not
their left catboy had a breakout 2019 36
homers 90 rpis
check back to Second it sails away and
both Runners will move up
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
second base
and you know I don't think that's a ball
that
that Garcia couldn't handle
just misjudged it
both Runners move up second and third
three one count
base hit scores two
and now a full count
this would be the definition of locking
down with runners in scoring position
right now there are two of them
still looking for someone to break the
ice so far today
grow with a slider
worked
Derek crochet picks up two strikeouts in
the fourth two more in the fifth with a
little pressure two scoreless innings
though we've played five
thirty years ago I fell in love in
October I've been trying to recreate
that feeling ever since
so let's take it back to game six
the Metrodome
11 Innings team I was sitting just rows
behind where Kirby's home run landed
and then there was game seven
and the greatest World Series of all
time
coincidentally thrown by a fellow kid
from Saint Paul it was only right we
went 10 innings
and ended at one nothing with a walk-off
[Music]
the 91 collection Honors that Legacy and
pays tribute to our hometown
our early years and our greatest moment
there's no memory I cherish more and I
couldn't be more grateful than to bring
you the official 30th Anniversary drop
honoring the 1991 World Series champions
your Minnesota Twins
[Music]
thank you
here we talk about what's been working
for Bailey oberg so far this afternoon
we talked earlier in the broadcast about
his fastball elevated up in the strike
zone he's being able to get
strikeouts by swinging and one strikeout
looking all fastballs elevated 93 to 94
miles an hour
you're gonna throw it as fastball away
he needs to throw it as you can see with
the two punch outs against Vaughn all
those fastball in and elevated against
him you can see he's used that four
seamer 50 out of 74 pitches
slider chain chip curveball
big Bailey Ober start number 13 in his
career and start to Bray you with a high
fastball
you know very rarely this day and age
you see guys being able to pitch with
their fastballs and you you have two of
them in this ballpark you have
Lance Lynn and baby over those guys can
use their fastball you know over 50 of
the time where that's not the case
anymore it makes me baseball it's
usually you know
50 50 split or less than that
look at where he releases the baseball
too
extension is was that about six feet
more I think seven I think it's seven
three seven point for him which is the
same Mark as Tyler glass now
who when he's healthy is one of the best
In The Biz
and very tall
see that fastball is right down the
middle
being able to show
and Vaughn some of these big hitters in
this White Sox lineup you know fastballs
in
you know just make just a little
hesitant hesitant to jump out there and
try to get to some of those other
fastballs and that's why you see those
pictures like that just fouling back
instead of on top of them and that's
going to get past second Polanco can't
handle it
I mean there is not much hard contact
today off Bailey over but Jose brayu
picks up a base hit his first of the
afternoon
I mentioned earlier about the adjustment
that these White Sox hitters have made
over the last couple years and giving
taking what the defense has given them
you can see
he's a home run hitter but he's also he
can hit for average and he wasn't afraid
to take what Ober gave him he shot that
ball to right field because he saw the
big open spot in the in the infield for
the twins how they were playing him to
pull he took what they gave him
here's example a Elia Menace
two base hits today
most of what's been leaving is that
lately has gone a long way
it's got some home runs since been
activated off the IL
but today both his hits one been a
broken back single to just in front of
Jake Haven Centerfield and a ground ball
up the middle
so you know he's even though he's two
for two
against Bailey oberg right now baby
oberge winning because keeping the ball
in the ballpark and that was one of you
know one of the things I spoke about he
has to keep the ball in the ballpark
against this team because they
you're like the twins I mean you're not
going to pitch them tough they're going
to take advantage and they're not
playing small ball it's about big ball
with these teams
that one's to left gliding back is
larnik for the catch and the first out
in the sixth
and our third poll question today on
YouTube easy to play along
grab your mobile device or if you're
watching on your computer screen it's
right in front of you first off I want
to show you the AL postseason picture
rays lead the division White Sox up big
in the central the Astros up by two
games and your wild card teams at the
moment Oakland and Boston nice Ovation
here for Bailey over as well
great job by Bailey oberg
gave a chance of Team a very good chance
to win this game
new picture coming in hold that thought
pull question coming in
in just a moment
welcome to a place where you will
guaranteed find out something about the
Chicago White Sox past present and
future that you didn't know
[Music]
you are now watching Sox TV
[Music]
I trust everything I throw it doesn't
matter what I'm throwing whatever I
throw I'm better than the hill
far
his kind of pitches with
the ocean
[Applause]
I don't think I can do it I don't think
I can succeed I'm gonna prove you wrong
watch me
foreign
watch all out of Market regular season
games live or on demand plus MLB
beginning I love that show I hosted
sometimes exclusively on MLB.TV
blackouts and other restrictions apply
visit MLB.TV for details gorgeous day in
Minneapolis
sun shining
temps in the high 80s low 90s
I showed you the division standings two
minutes ago now we'd like to know which
Al team has the best chance to reach the
World Series is it one of the current
division leaders or none of the above
AKA other that's an option as well with
Troy stay hot I'm gonna go with the
astrals
you like what they're bringing to the
table I love them you know their ability
to score runs they're leading the
American League and run scored I'm not
mistaken
they have a really good Bullpen and
closer Ryan Presley
and Altuve has been outstanding this
year 25 26 home runs so far
they lead the major leagues and runs
scored you are correct they don't strike
out much this guy
can pick up some swinging Miss Caleb
thielbar
34 years old the Minnesota native and
really a great story he takes over for
Bailey Ober who had himself a day
the billboard last pitched on Saturday
against the Astros gave up two runs it's
been throwing the ball very well you got
a fastball 87-94 slider 78-84 and a
curveball his curveball is a really good
pitch a lot of
12-6 action
you can change the speeds on it
what's unusual about Bill bar he's able
to throw a slider from that arm slot
which a lot of guys you don't see with
that arm slot higher up
and able to throw a slider it's usually
four seam and a curveball but he's added
a slider to his his repertoire
and down on strikes is Brian Goodwin so
Theo bar enters
and picks up a strikeout now two down in
the sixth
showed him a slaughtered and came back
with a fastball and you see that four
seam just true as can be
backspin Goodman swings straight through
that pitch I just wanted to remind you
about the odds courtesy of bet MGM when
you said yeah I'll take a two-nothing
game
we've got zeros over under at nine and a
half
touching pitchers so far a lot of game
left
we talked about it a lot I mean first
off
Ronaldo Lopez has been really good when
he has appeared for the White Sox this
season gave them three solid Innings and
then if you watched Bailey over starts
recently you see
a young pitcher developing into
a big leader I mean he looks like he
belongs
all right you get an opportunity to
learn on the job and as you can see this
probably his fourth time fifth time
facing the White Sox so he's faced his
team
a lot this season and you know he's
gotten better each each time he's faced
him that's because his stuff has gotten
better
remember what he what these guys done to
him and what he needed to do to them to
be successful you're right five times
against the White Sox and he keeps
picking up Steve so now catches the
pop-up in foul grounds and Jose Abreu is
stranded mid six in Minnesota
back jumps and makes the catch
it's the best compliment you can pay me
when that guy from Wall Street Journal
called me last year and said we did a
survey and you're number one
your number one home in baseball I said
we just made my day
[Applause]
not quite out of here God damn it
[Music]
when we lose there's not one person in
that Clubhouse
who was more upset than I am
pops him up
Gillespie and now Beckham
and we find yet another way
that's hard to believe you gotta be
kidding me
you have got to be kidding me
[Applause]
[Music]
play ball is baseball and softball's
initiative to highlight the fun and
accessible ways to play the game for all
find a league near you go to
playball.org and follow at playball on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram MLB
Originals season 2 is Live on YouTube
with new episodes every week see your
favorite players and learn more about
the game you love on youtube.com MLB
Scott Braun LaTroy Hawkins Lauren
Gardner bringing you the action live
from Target Field we're on the road for
our MLB game of the week Live on YouTube
for the first time this season and now
we're watching Jose Ruiz the 26 year old
with an era in the three and a half
range
next up out of the bullpen after Lopez
and crochet
White Sox just keep running guys out
there who throw 95 plus miles an hour
the good queso
Louise fastball curveball change up 94
to 100 with his four seam fastball with
some good carry
curveball 83-90 change up 88 to 91 miles
an hour and he started out as a catcher
in the Padres system decided to pitch in
2016. it's working out
he breaks worker off from the first
pitch slider for a strike
[Music]
two strikeouts today for Rooker
strikes against him
they're going right after him
steady guy there's Sliders fastballs in
[Music]
you hadn't made much contact today but
I've seen him hit a ball in the third
deck here in left field on a hanging
slider and it was loud and it was far
paint on the corner from Ruiz
now this is an outfield full of former
first rounders who talked about caroloff
and Rucker
larnik what about Byron Buxton I mean
this is a special talent and the problem
has been keeping them on the field and
actually the latest injury for him was
on a hit by pitch
and two days after you come back from
his
um his hip injury and it was just a sad
day but when he's out there he brings so
much to this team
first pitch swinging Polanco it's going
a long way Engel gives it a look forget
about it
Jorge Polacco muscles up and the twins
are on the board first
number 21 on the season he is the rock
of the offense
[Applause]
milocco's been swinging about well for
the last you know 40 50 games he got him
a fastball all over the plate
didn't either Turn and Burn on that
because the ball was just a little bit
away from him he'd drove that ball right
into the White Sox bullpen for a solo
shot
first pitch knocks off the glove and
it's cleaned up by Ruiz out number two
that's nice Pops from your second
baseman
Apple Taco he's been hitting the ball
pulling the ball alive doing his high
streak with some Authority
but it shows you he has the ability to
to hit the ball out of the ballpark
without having to pull it
[Music]
416 feet that's a long way
it's a good home run rate in your last
couple weeks 7 and 13 games
we had an incredible
10-game Road Trip the twins just got off
of on Sunday coming from taking three
out of four in Houston with an
exclamation point on Sunday he puts two
over the wall
this man's capable of doing damage too
despite the Twins record they've half
played better recently
yeah it was the
surprisingly slow start for the
back-to-back division champs
they've been 500-ish
since the nightmare
when did the nightmare start it's March
31st pretty much for about a month
you can lose your way out of a division
race really quickly
and going to the season you know
everybody in this division knew that it
was there was a good chance there's
going to be a dog fight with two teams
the White Sox and the twins I hadn't
shook off that way the White Sox have
definitely took control of this division
they're young they're athletic they're
exciting they have the best rotation
very good Bullpen they have the they
have all the components and all the
pieces that they need to win a
championship and not just the Central
division championship I'm talking about
a World Series championship
[Music]
and impact position players coming back
it feels like once a week now
Jimenez and it's Robert Randall soon
just started a rehab assignment that was
announced today
I remember very vividly being in spring
training when Eloy Jimenez got hurt
and you know just thinking like wow
that's a huge blow to them how are they
going to make up for that that
production in their in their lineup
because left field you know he's he's
not that he's not above average Defender
okay but what he brings to the plate is
far more valuable to this team and they
were able to do it all the decisions
that they made all the guys that they
brought up
to to fill that void all played
extremely well it's been a revolving
door in the outfields
credit to the White Sox front office
for finding Replacements that played at
an above average rate
keep credit to guys like Joe McEwen
Franklin Aquino Jerry Narron
Miguel Gonzalez Louis Sierra just guys
who who are there you know Shelly Duncan
Howie Clark Miguel Cairo Daryl boss just
guys who've been around the game a long
time understand how to get a player
prepared to you know to be as successful
as possible and larussa given giving
them the ability to go out and do their
work
Tony knows how to build a coaching staff
yeah and I really enjoyed our
conversation with him today that was
that was money
[Applause]
ball forces two out base runner
we're listening to larussa give you know
some other managers a lot of credit he
spoke about his conversation here with
Tom Kelly and you know the mutual
respect they have for one another just
from you know competing against each
other all over the years and not just
respect between the managers the respect
that each organization these team have
for each other
see Jerry niran on the screen
this is Jay cave strike one from Ruiz
I mean Tony where's that ring around I
mean he's got a few but
when you're having a conversation with
someone and you look down you go he's
got he's got one of those World Series
rings I'm going after it holds a little
more juice
yeah I mean he has a resume that's for
sure no doubt he has a baseball card and
he has a resume as a manager you know
getting the most out of his players
a lot of managers
a lot of managers don't aren't able to
do that they don't have that that magic
and I like to call it magic because
every guy doesn't have it
I like to say Rocco has that magic of
getting the best out of his players and
being able to put them in positions
where they can be the most they have a
chance to be the most successful
he is extremely well liked yes within
the organization it's very easy to see
why
just talking to larussa also and he was
talking about the respect that he has
for Rocco bardelli and that's coming
from a guy who's
been in the game of baseball longer than
he's been living all this manager versus
youngest manager advantage today
youngest manager thanks to his most
consistent bat this season Jorge Polanco
powering up and the twins are trying to
grab this series
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a no-hitter after everything he's been
through the elbow and the shoulder were
Supreme on April 14 20 21. here's the
pitch sheets with a blast away
it's gone White Sox win it
oh what a shot by Kevin sheets Gavin
sheets on a 3-1 fastball he let it go it
only needs one is bad to come to him
[Music]
do not walk anyone in front of him
wow welcome back hi Mom see you later
bye three
[Music]
[Applause]
we're into the seventh one-nothing Twins
and the home team has been missing their
Superstar for most of the Season as he's
played in only 36 percent of their game
since 2018. it's a long injury list we
saw him this morning Byron Buxton in
about a month's work this year he looked
like an MVP he's that special he's also
developed his personality his leadership
within the clubhouse and it looks like
he's on his way back soon well Troy the
problem for him lately is the left hand
fracture on a hit by pitch but as you
can see it's just been some Misfortune
and some breakdowns in terms of the body
but I mean he's still young and oozing
with potential he is and we saw probably
the best what 36 games of you know his
career like like you say it was MVPs and
you know once the twins get him back in
the lineup and I'm hoping that he gets
all his injuries behind him and he can
just finish his career with no more
hiccups
um he's the type of player he's a
general generational type player his
athleticism his power his arm
you know his ability to run
but we got to get him on the field and
when he's on the field we already know
he's the best player on the field
this is the latest June 21st what two
days back
you just come back Tyler Malley really
throws for the Heat
fractures the left hand
just come back in Texas Father's Day
weekend
and wasn't back two days and he took a
fastball off of the the hand and I
remember I was at home watching it in
the theater and I just started screaming
and my wife what's wrong with you and
I'm like you have no idea I'm like that
did not look good he just got back I
mean
Byron can't buy a break
but through all the injuries
attitude's been great energy has been
unbelievable it's working his behind off
you know getting this work in trying to
get back and you know sometimes when you
got you know a lead athlete like that
you have to
protect him from himself sometimes
because he's
I think he's ready and you know even
though he's still better than a lot of
other people when he's at 90 percent we
need him to be 100 when he goes back on
the field
especially for a team now that is
thinking about 2022 giving looks to
younger players
there's some guys that
that has benefited from him being on the
IO lamb pulls it to right Kepler is
there
[Applause]
young outfielders Galore kiriloff larnik
Rooker all former first round picks all
young all picking up playing time
kiriloff unfortunately down for the rest
of the season with the wrist surgery but
this is a chance for the twins for the
first time in a few years to see what
they've got with some of the youngsters
because they didn't have time for that
and Rocco baldelli said we've had a
veteran Club the last few seasons they
won the AL Central last year and the
year before the year before that's where
the bomba Squad nickname came up 101
wins there's been a lot of success
within this organization the problem is
it's well documented playoff record not
much winning in the postseason it's been
a minute
you had to throw you know two other guys
on that that board you just show shown
with the outfielders you got that Nick
Gordon he plays center field and had
never played in the Outfield before and
his first time playing was in a major
league game and played center field but
that just attachment to his athleticism
and Rob refsnyder
um he had a he had a month playing in
the Outfield where he was he had been
very good he brought into production
offensively that this team needed he
added that extra you know push extra
shot in the arm and he played a very
good center field and I don't think he
had plays in to fill that off that that
much as well no
it's a new position for Rob and also a
bit of a new swing for him has given him
better results and then don't forget
about Austin Martin who comes over in
the Jose burrillos trade he can kind of
play everywhere you potential to be in
the outfield for them as well
it's overall pick by the Toronto Blue
Jays I had Austin in the Futures game
and he played shortstopping
and I think he got a couple of bats but
just watching this ability to control
the Baton his eye and her number feed he
had 11 pitch it back during that game
it's very impressive
ball foreign Garcia is a one-out base
runner in the seventh for the White Sox
down a run
all right ear muffs twins fans sorry
it's a global broadcast I gotta do it
some people are not aware of the longest
ever postseason losing streak that is
off and running right now since
2004-18 consecutive losses last time
they picked up a w in October it was
2004 ALDS game one against the New York
Yankees
this is including all the North American
Pro Sports last time they won a playoff
series yeah
and it's not like it's a franchise
that's
been full of losing I mean there's been
some division titles since then oh look
at that look look behind Zach Collins
you see the sign that
TC
has Tyler Troy hi TC how you doing good
to see you that's well done Collins
spits one the left it's fading towards
the line and larnik is there for the
catch and moving up to second in there
safely is leori Garcia with two gone now
in the seventh
flashback to 2004.
last W for the Minnesota Twins
organization in the playoffs was at
Yankee Stadium ALDS game one there it is
Joe Nathan versus Ruben Sierra
are you still there
for no
no I left after
half
2003
yeah it's a good W's there 2002 and 2003
division titles
see you looking up to TC
yes
we see UTC uh LaTroy and the twins
mascot going back and forth right now
while there's a pitching change
two outs in the seventh that's it for
Caleb thielbar I'll show us the sign I
wish you could hear us right now we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
so he can get himself a hang and break
the ball
high fly left center field and Miguel
Sano says that's enough
he got a hang and breaking ball and he
ended it
a walk-off two-run home run
twins in 12 prevail
you pitch a Fly ball into right field
and deep back and goes deep it goes
unbelievable
Ben roarkbin to right field a no doubter
nine nine in the ninth inning
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
-nothing twins off of Polanco solo shot
and another YouTube poll in the book
sale team with the best chance to reach
the World Series there are the White Sox
fans showing up big 53 of the pole AL
Central leaders at the moment plenty of
White Sox fans tuning in right now and
we appreciate your participation
hey the Twins won this division the
prior two years and now they're loading
up for the future it's like a mini
reload right is that a fair assessment
plus yeah I'll say a menu they're
building build battle we're gonna say
rebuild
these are two big parts of the future of
the twins organization they pick them up
in the Jose Barrios trade from the Blue
Jays Austin Martin and Simeon Woods
Richardson you've got a great bat who
can play a number of different spots and
a big Arm coming over to Minnesota for a
player who might impact the postseason
race quite a bit Jose Barrios who had a
nice career with the Minnesota Twins and
now we'll spend at least the next one
and a half Seasons with the Blue Jays
taking over Juan Manaya with two outs
here in the seventh and a runner in
scoring position behind him who can move
Yuri Garcia worked a one-out walk
Collins flew out and now it's Cesar
Hernandez having a big time power year
career-high 20 homers
huge not as big for him you know see the
average is 237 going base percentage 317
but those power numbers from your second
baseman and that's you know that's kind
of like reminiscent of Brian Dozier
yeah it's legit too career best exit
velocity Barrel percentage the launch
angle is significantly up makes sense
fly balls he's crushing fastballs hit
three homers last year in 60 games
he did that in a few games to start the
season and he has not slowed down
give him some good pitches to hit
he's trying to put him in place trying
to do some real damage
pick up the punch out 96 Hernandez
thought it was low
a little back and forth but that's going
to do it for the inning Garcia stranded
at second
I know LaTroy is calling it a strike
well no that ball was down oh you know
but you hadn't seen Manny Gonzalez call
the ball down you've seen him giving
more up but not down I thought the
pitcher would say no that's good honesty
unfair
[Applause]
from the cornfields of Iowa the Field of
Dreams plays host to the Yankees and the
White Sox
in the game of baseball there was a
special place
they have built it and now we have come
it is in heaven but it's pretty darn
close
[Music]
thank you
oh that Field of Dreams game is going to
be special the New York Yankees with
some classic uni Sanchez DJ lemaki will
be there for a Yankees team that's been
playing pretty good baseball labor
Torres on the injured list right now
our judge I want to see what he does
with a baseball in the corn fields to
work with
unfortunately Tony larussa won't be
making the trip there was a death in the
family so he will make a quick trip out
to pay a visit and then come back to the
White Sox on Saturday for their next
game against the Yankees that'll be in
Chicago and
he's still there you stayed in the game
he just wanted to get a little word on
the uh
vertical aspect of the strike zone from
the last half inning and Juan Manaya
picking up the strikeout to escape
Now Matt Foster into the game and just
called up today with Carlos rodon
hitting the Shelf
28th game this season for the White Sox
just got called up from AAA Charlotte
era is about half that number in AAA
Foster was really good down there
coming back up as an extra arm
and White Sox fans that are worried
about Carlos Rodan at least from our
perspective having conversations with
the organization it sounds like just
some soreness and he'll be back pretty
quickly also keeping in mind that he
hasn't pitched a ton he's dealt with
injuries so this is a lengthy season for
him it's not the worst thing in the
world for a team that's got a
double-digit lead in the division no
no giving him you know a 10-day rest a
break in the middle of the season
so you can you know recharge his battery
and get ready for you know some October
pitching
there's a win for the White Sox
organization Jeffers strikes out
you mentioned Foster hit a 2-2 ERA last
year a little elevated this year
but you know if you could fastball at 90
to 95 we'll throw a slider but he has a
plus change up so the change up his
predominantly his best pitch
[Music]
stuff wise this bullpen's ridiculous
I mean this guy would be a big part of
many other bullpens
I'm sure the acquisition of Craig
Kimbrel didn't help him that much and
it's kopeck it's Kimbrough it's crochet
of course Liam Hendricks the big
off-season signing
Brian to para moved over from the Cubs
foreign
not sure if he was actually thinking
about laying it down
definitely
drew the attention of Jake Lamb in third
base
[Music]
when you see bot do you think
differently for the next pitch I guess
nowadays you're not expecting him to
double up so it doesn't really matter
right well nowadays you're not expecting
him to bite ever ever exactly just
continue to pitch
but if you square around a bun I like to
throw one like at your face and it's
just not as comfortable learning to left
Jimenez
got it
two away in the seventh get exclusive
content from your favorite team the
Chicago White Sox head on over to
youtube.com White Sox and hit that
subscribe button today
Scott when the movie was premiered Field
of Dreams in 1989
well you're a lot younger I'm sorry but
did you think that movie was gonna stand
the test of time like I mean it was a
good movie yeah but I didn't think I
didn't know that it would you know 30
years 32 years later it would be
man I'm that's that's pretty cool it's
the Aesthetics for me
I thought that's what stood out right
the cinematography and how cool that
field looked and I know there was
recently a sit-down interview with Kevin
Costner talking to Bob Costas and Kevin
said you know after this shoot I would I
would keep these fields I think we've
got something special here and I'm glad
they kind of preserved that whole area
so that we can do what we're doing
tomorrow back in Iowa
that's what stood out to me what about
you
I hadn't watched it in decades I told
you that earlier I mean it's you know
I'm really not into baseball movies
um just documentaries about baseball not
movies documentaries but
okay guys I have to interject here I'm
loving this conversation La Troy though
when you asked
what process was if it would withstand
the test of time when it came out in 89.
Scott should we put up a poll how old
were you I don't give that away I love
that me neither I'm gonna be 25 forever
it's 20 21. everybody knows how old you
are except for me
[Music]
I came out in 89 no I was a sophomore in
high school sorry I was trying to give
you a little bit of leeway oh I'm 48 I
have no problem my Quan's wedding I was
getting ready to get drafted two years
later
my grandfather told me a long time ago
never resent growing old many were
denied the privilege
that's right I like that
thank you
you talk about the cinematology
Aesthetics
it's in 2017 it was selected for
preservation for the United States
national film registry
by the Library of Congress for
culturally historically or has
aesthetically significant Simmons to
right and there's Goodwin to run it down
and it's my fives for everyone on his
way back to the dugout
three up three down in the seventh we
move on to the eighth pitchers duel
today bullpen's taking over and looking
nice
when I played I'd be standing in right
field killer brood come to the plate
lawn work and be on the mound he'd punch
him in the Odyssey grab some bench or he
gone he gone yeah grab some [ __ ] for
out number two that's it deep way back
way back put it on the board that came
from golf
uh
they gave me an exemption in
76-77 to play at Pleasant Valley in
Sutton Mass you know the PGA Tour
stopped there I buried this par three
knocked in about a 20-footer
and back they didn't have electronic
scoreboards in those days they had
manual school boards and it was a guy
with a pipe from an older guy and he was
reading a book you know and he's not
moving the guy he's
I looked at him I said Put it on the
board like that
and then where the yes came from was our
daughter Krista who was a terrific
competitive diver she'd go on footboard
and when he [ __ ] yes
so one day
somebody hits a home run
and I said you can put it on the board
oh yes
that boat hit hard stay Fair he looks up
you can put it on
[Music]
one nothing twins off of Jorge Polanco
Home Run and check out some former Cubs
wearing White Sox Unis you know if the
White Sox win a World Series this year
next year whatever the cups are going to
play a big part of it let's be real
LaTroy Jimenez NC is coming over in the
Jose cantana deal and now some Bullpen
help with tapera and Kimbrell this year
for the stretch run as Juan Manaya is
back to work in the eighth you know what
they call that been a friendly neighbor
hey I like that friendly neighbor
they didn't trade him in division in the
division they traded him out of division
out of the league which is fine
three pitches quick strikeout for Juan
Manaya
third K of the day for Andrew Vaughn
he's over four
okay so Jose abreu's up Miguel Sano is
at first base today and those two had a
conversation and we're lucky because
Miguel's miked up
ladies and gentlemen I'm here in the
first Bay with one of the best hitter in
the American League MVP last year
Jose April
he's so stinking show
uh they're gonna love him on play Loud
the YouTube show that really collects
all of that
money content and puts it together on
YouTube each week and you also know
miked up today that was a one-man
interview yeah exactly
Jose might not know he's miked up so
he's probably like why is he evaporating
no he's probably saying why isn't he
speaking Spanish
what's wrong come on now Miguel
espanol vamanos
the Bro with a base hit his last time up
made one for three today 84 RBIs and
he's a machine in that category for
years look at Juan Manaya go
he's a machine when guys are out there
on base pads there's a really good
chance he's gonna he's gonna bring him
around the score just a really good
changeup from Manaya you can see Roberto
he actually foul tip that ball into
Jeffrey's glove for the strikeout
he don't like to strike out
going up against the Heavy Hitters in
the eighth inning
Anaya struck out Vaughn and Abreu now
it's Jimenez
Malloy playing Left Field today I was
curious to ask Tony larussa about the
difference between Jimenez
as an outfielder versus being a DH and
the conversation goes hey you're the
same guy
because alloy likes to play in the field
sometimes feels like he's he's better at
the plate when he gets time in the
outfields but
there are other excellent outfielders
that are part of the mix also Jimenez
coming off an injury so they're like
just
since like Russo said just
when you're hitting just hit just hit
doesn't make a difference if you're DH
in that day or you playing out in left
left field when you're up to the plate
just hit that's all we want you to do
that's what I was looking for what are
the wise words that you give him to tell
him that he's going to be fine either
way and it's exactly what you just
mentioned that's the line
and there he goes to right
Kepler back at the wall guy
it's a quick eighth for Juan Manaya
strikeout strikeout and then Jimenez
with not enough mustard on the baseball
to put the White Sox on the board still
one nothing mid eight
is there ever a time where you're just
like you know what I quit I don't want
to do this anymore
yeah matter of fact it was uh it was
after I got drafted though so
started my career off over 26 called my
dad I'm like you know when I'm coming
home I I ain't want to do this no more
and he's like no you're not all right
you got it and the next day
I see him pulling up through the fence
and I'm like he literally drove through
the night you know to come watch this
game or whatever and that was first
first game I hit my first home run uh in
pro ball so it's one of those where it
was
I think I was a little a little homesick
maybe I've never went away from my
parents until I got got the pro ball so
one of those where I just
something happened you know I prayed
that night that
just allow me to get hit today and
everything be fine and you know I see my
family my mom my dad my sister come to
the gate you know that that put a sense
of uh happiness in me and
like I said I got my first hit uh first
first home run as a hit and uh it was it
was a great day
[Music]
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube shorts
watching create videos on YouTube try
shorts in the YouTube app on your phone
Scott Brown LaTroy Hawkins Lauren
Gardner letting you know you can go
behind the scenes and watch exclusive
interviews and learn more about your
favorite players on the Twins YouTube
channel head over to youtube.com twins
subscribe to the twins today
we're in the ballpark
oh it feels good to be here in Detroit
seriously yes indeed I missed the smells
the crowd
back on the road for the rest of the
season for our MLB game of the week Live
on YouTube and we get to watch Craig
Kimbrel in person
popping up for the White Sox
and so far three and two thirds three
earned runs four strikeouts no walks
with Chicago you're looking at his line
on the season and a six double O era and
41 appearances in 19 and 20. well guess
what in 2021 he's back and that means it
took a big Hall to get him the Cubs pick
up Nick Madrigal and Cody Boyer for
Craig Kimbrel who's I guess you can't
technically have him after this season
you can pick up the option so it could
be more than a season's worth of Craig
Campbell but it also could be just a
hired few months of one of the best
relievers in Major League Baseball and
we get to watch him right now in the
home eighth for a twins team that has a
one-nothing lead first pitch swinging is
Max Kepler and that's Adam Engel to line
it up and put him away well
Kimber was one of my favorite pictures
just just watching him you know his
Focus his ability to just attack hitters
in the zone
you know you know that year in 2019 he
ended up signing late and those guys man
I tell you pitchers who signed late they
usually never have a good season you
might might have a couple over the years
but the big picture most of the guys
don't have good years and it takes some
time to get back into that mode that
they were in before you know that that
spring training remember Lance Lynn when
he signed with Minnesota he couldn't
find the Zone you're like wait this
isn't Lance Lynn this is a guy who's
always throwing strikes
and it took him some time and signed
with we got traded to the Yankees it was
a messy seven eight starts and then he
looked like Lance Lynn after that
he's even better since then and he
pitches tomorrow for Chicago
[Music]
Hendrix eight nine for the rest of the
season
as I mentioned Kimball had his struggles
for those couple Seasons but he is back
in a big way
eight-time All-Star with a career year
well most of the time you people talk
about his fastballing
you know always said his breaking ball
was devastating
and that made his
that made his fastball that much better
how good is breaking balls or he is
each of these White Sox hitters just
went up there just challenged Brent
Rooker with you know sliders and
fastballs and hadn't been able to put
anything in play three strikeouts so far
today my back hurts when I watch him set
up
Nobody Does it Like That
very intimidating yes see if we get to
see the breaking ball
there it is Rooker stays alive
true story about 10 years ago
I hosted a Craig Kimbrel stare down
contest
he went up against fans at the MLB fan
cave in New York City
it's on YouTube
I like it yeah I'll show you later it
was funny
it's pretty intimidating
he won most of those battles
2-2
see those last two breaking balls from
Kimbrough they were just
never got horizontal they were just
hovering around
another
middle end of the plate he's trying to
get that ball you know down in the way
to the right hand hit her
Brett Rucker
[Music]
a lot of reports that he he hadn't been
spotting up his fastball this year he's
had some success he's just trying to
throw it somewhere hard in his own
and the Bugaboo I guess the one thing
you could go against the line is the
walks but he's tightened that up this
year as well good A B from Brent Roker
so far
yeah I don't mind the walks when you're
striking out about 12 to 13 per nine and
you have less hits than any pitch he
doesn't mind them either no unfazed with
Runners on you've seen it sometimes
roller coaster finishes but usually he
wins the matchup in the end but what you
don't want and that's a recipe for
disaster if you're walking guys giving
up hits and you're not striking anybody
else out and there's another one
it's four strikeouts tonight this
afternoon for Brent rookers right
okay we'll say he's gonna done messing
around with the breaking ball see if I
can get a fastball just over the top of
his hands middle end
high heat
Sports gaming Universe in the live game
commentary section said never expected a
one-nothing game today
well I think we had a we had a feeling
that it was going to be a pitchers duel
Day game after a night game White Sox
looking forward to tomorrow classic
battle tomorrow in Iowa against the
Yankees
two underrated pitchers that started
this game
and then bullpens represented
Alex collime
to pitch the ninth
all right so here's Polanco actually
took the first pitch but
he's swinging at the first pitch more
than ever in his career 22 and a half
percent on the season
he's been aggressive and it's working
for him sometimes it might be the best
pitch you get
he's picking his spots when you need to
jump on that first pitch and
the Third
[Applause]
pick couldn't clear the wall Polanco is
going to end up racing the third with a
triple
oh he thought about racing home a little
little league Style
eight feet short of clearing the wall
[Applause]
triple number two on the season for
Jorge Polanco
[Music]
got him a pitch middle
in slightly elevated
just wasn't able to get it over that
high wall and right field here at Target
Field
but nonetheless the triple
with two outs and
the twins can figure out a way to get
this run home and give Alex calling me a
two-run lead going into the ninth ninth
inning for a while I think he thought he
had it
I thought he had it
to Ryan is fouling off the first pitch
[Music]
not an easy play but the ball is
you know behind him and he saw once he
saw it hit off the brick wall out there
and bounce that far away from Goodwin he
figured he had a really good shot at
getting the third base
and Rocco talked about when we got guys
on base who do you want hitting he's
spoke of Luis arise because he's going
to put the ball in play
it's been pretty clutch
he's the only guy in the lineup
hitting over 300.
foreign
YouTube channel in the live chat says
Polanco POG player of the game we have
that poll coming soon
I mean
he's leading the pack at the moment
that's right now yes indeed yeah right
now yes Homer triple
not much offense
Bailey over can make a case too shutting
down this lineup that's true he sure can
you throw zeros up there but you can't
win with all zeros somebody on your team
gonna have to score
and I don't I don't want you to think
believing here Scott that I'm against
pictures no I know but I'm trying to see
it from both perspectives
Blanca is the only twins opening day
starting position player that's avoided
the injured list and sometimes he has
battled through injuries played through
them a rise to Center and it's gonna
hang up long enough for angle to make
the catch and end the a so no extra
insurance for the twins almost a home
run from Polanco would have been his
second of the day instead it's a triple
he's left to Third and we've played
eight one nothing Minnesota
let's go
Sox did have an edge for the 162 game
grind an inspirational man of
indomitable Spirit come on get those run
by Boy let's go the Aussie Factor AJ
let's go could you guys understand him
come out don't get hurt I think that's
the biggest thing most people can't
understand him make it happen let's go
don't wait you deal with the manager
every day that is the closest candy you
ever been around your life you have to
talk to be a leader he wants to type a
kid like he's gotta go foreign
[Music]
keeps guys loose he brings a lot of
energy in the clubhouse and in the in
the Dugout let's go come on let's go
keep fighting boys he's really been in
the middle of this Clubhouse day in and
out bringing this team together from day
one I got 25 guys there that God can
take it anywhere with me those guys go
anywhere with me and I'll go with them
Aussie ball to me is just you know
playing the fundamental Baseball playing
the game the way it's supposed to be
played
gonna hit the left field that scores the
tying run here comes presenting of the
play and the White Sox have taken the
lead four to three this is an
unbelievable thing they got going here
in Chicago they're playing the game the
way it's supposed to be played
[Music]
[Music]
so the difference today is that gas
powered by Google Cloud Jorge Polanco
continuing to impress in the second half
of the Season opposite field with that
shot he's so locked in he is so locked
in right now he's a pole hitter he is
and he's been pulling the ball with a
lot of authority
hit that his triple hit that ball high
off the right field wall you know good
when plated got just a little too close
to it because he thought it was gone as
well but just hit the ball hard and it's
been able to hit the ball all over the
field as you can see from his home runs
into the left center field Gap
one nothing twins Alex collame to try
and shut the door for a second
consecutive day
42 saves with the White Sox in 19 and
20.
[Music]
picked up by the twins for this season
very Rocky beginning to the year for him
he loves his cutter he's picked up his
pace
save number six of the season for him
yesterday in a 4-3 W the White Sox have
dominated the season series but the
twins are playing them very well this
week yeah they've played better the
twins played better
as a whole against all their opponents
the last 14 days so or less
but you know I've seen him struggle
throughout the this season and you know
there's one thing to struggle and it's
another to be you know a bad guy in the
clubhouse that hasn't been out of Alex
Holloman he has been the ultimate
professional throughout his struggles
and a lot of times you don't get that
you know you usually get guys who want
to pitching well they're you know
they're good in the clubhouse when
they're not pitching well they're Debbie
downers and that's that hadn't been him
this year he's been all in uh going out
there every day trying to get better and
you know it's gotten better at times for
him but he's definitely not where he
would like to be at
the 4-3 win last night for Minnesota
column A pitched the ninth
here we go again
he'll use that cutter about 66 percent
of the time two-thirds of his pitches
it's fastball forcing fastball is 92-95
but his cutter is 87 to 93 with some of
the same movement coming out of the same
arm saw as basketball
into the shifts
Goodwin is the first down
[Music]
so Miguel Sano makes the catch from
Jorge Polacco and Miguel Sano has some
thoughts on Polanco's long ball
get out
you're the best Papa I tell you what a
hitter
opposite field
opposite way
21.
wow Jorge
he's showing the power
I think we have ourselves a future
broadcaster and Elsa no mic'd up and he
knows it
it's so cool too just to see how far
he's coming so comfortable Now using you
know speaking English and that's just a
testament to him his hard work and
Polanco as well both those guys are very
good speaking English and they work hard
at it
Adam angle
ball and strike
remember the combo from the beginning of
the game when snow was quizzing Polanco
about his approach and Blanco's like I'm
just trying to go up the middle hit the
ball hard every time which is
interesting coming from a pull hitter
and then he does
go deep up the middle
angle deep Center
[Applause]
okay it runs it down
two adds in the nine
alamingo hit a fastball yesterday
straight away center field for a home
run
and that pitch right there was a cutter
kind of backed up a little bit it's a
really good pitch
wasn't able to get all of that
two outs in the ninth inning
Last Chance Jake Lamb
singled in the fifth
just a day off for yawn moncada
[Applause]
we'll be back in there tomorrow
Lamb's a former All-Star
and hit 59 home runs in 2016 and 17.
look at that bench that's a stacked
bench moncada Anderson Robert and the
catchers of olive
what they came after a night game and
the rusoff did gives him his
star players
the afternoon off
nice crowd today in Minneapolis
beautiful day for baseball
it's just good to see people are just
happy to be out over 22 000 filling up
Target Field today you're hearing it in
the ninth
[Music]
[Applause]
O2 from column A
cut her down see if you can get
Jake Lam the swing over top of that
Atlanta wasn't biting
foreign
[Applause]
this cutter
I tried
come on I wish that they could be I mean
not many I guess are tuning in on
YouTube right now maybe inside the
ballpark because that was that was not
pleasant no that was way out
oh well
don't boo Manny Gonzalez for them
all right let's see if Kyle may can find
the Zone on the 2-2
and it's a foul ball
this is the 19th meeting and finally
matchup of the Season between these two
teams
the White Sox have taken 13 of them
I'm sure the White Sox are upset they
don't get to face them anymore yep
okay
now three and two to Jake Lamb
with leori Garcia looming
[Music]
so far Alex column has been able to
continue to pitch lamb away
and not so far nothing over the heart of
the plate or middle end
which is conducive to a swing
if he makes contact he can hit it a long
way
hence the reason the twins are staying
away from them
and they continue to do so
picking around the edges and walking
Jake Lamb who comes back from 1-2
it's not a strike but
you know I think the difference he did
walk that guy but
early in the year he probably wouldn't
have walked him he probably would have
missed with something over the plate and
got hurt by it so his command is a lot
better I mean he did walk the guy but
we're talking about his ability to stay
away from the Nitro zone of the hitter
in a spot like that
[Music]
here's Garcia
first pitch for Polanco makes the play
game over
twins take it one nothing seventh save
of the season for Alex collime in the
50th win of the year for Minnesota
50 and 65 on the season Chicago 67 and
48 on the year and here comes the U2
player of the game question it's simple
is it badly over or Jorge Polanco
I'm gonna give it to Jorge Polanco
because he
he hit the Home Run the game ended one
nothing without that home run we're
sitting here getting ready to
see the bottom of the ninth inning and
possibly a walk-off so we already had to
walk off probably would have been the
player of the game also he might have
hit it
we'll see if they listen to you okay
let's hit the post game show
[Music]
the post game show is presented by
YouTube shorts Scott Braun LaTroy
Hawkins and Lauren Gardner will be
joining us soon as the twins pull off a
w and a series Victory they take two out
of three from the White Sox during the
week Chicago is going to move on to Iowa
yes first ever major league game played
in Iowa Field of Dreams game tomorrow
but maybe they were looking ahead a bit
also they were missing some pretty big
bats from the lineup today well yeah
they weren't but you know you got to get
a Twin's credit they went out there they
pitch not not much offense from neither
team it's just before he clock was able
to hit a home run uh give his team one
run and it happened to be enough to uh
to win the game today
you know just a well-pitched game for
those guys for the twins but it was a
lot of fun a lot of fun a fun game to
call and I enjoyed it I liked watching
the pitching listening to you go over
not only what the starters were able to
put together both of them were excellent
even though it was somewhat limited work
for Ronaldo Lopez as he's getting
stretched out again but Bailey Ober was
special and then the bullpens from both
sides really showing up big here on a
Wednesday afternoon you're right and
most of the good teams the White Sox
have an incredible Bullpen incredible
rotation he had one bad pitch Polanco
hit the ball out of the ballpark they
can live with that they didn't give up a
crooked number they went out there they
threw the ball over the plate they made
them put the ball in play the twins as
well they played a lot better the last
10 days I would say and a lot of that is
because of the way they've thrown the
ball over the plate and that's including
the starters and their relievers here's
your pick for the YouTube player of the
game we'll give you the poll results in
just a bit but joining us right now live
on YouTube it is Jorge Polanco with the
Home Run and later the triple Jorge
congrats on the w and first off let's go
through that home run for you because we
caught some sound as Miguel Sano was
miked up today you guys were having a
conversation and you and he said hey
what's the plan you're like up the
middle hit the ball hard and that's what
you did next step back yeah that's right
uh like you said we were talking um most
of the conversation where uh we gotta
get on top of the ball so I say yeah
let's get on top of the water and let's
go to the middle
you know Jorge we talk about how you're
healthy now and when your ankle wasn't
healthy you wasn't able to do some of
the things offensively or defensively
that you were doing back in 2019 when
you're an All-Star how are you feeling
now I'm feeling great uh you know uh
like you say I'm I'm feeling healthy uh
uh it's been it's been uh difficult
moment for me uh the last year but now
now that I'm healthy I feel I feel
uncomfortable I feel like I can't get
100 it sounds really good Zack has power
by Google Cloud we're showing the home
run along the opposite field into the
bullpen it went 416 feet would you say
that's the biggest reason why you've
really turned it up Jorge since the
month of July is it just that you feel
better than you have in the past couple
Seasons or was there any other tweaks
that were made lately uh I just feel
better you know I feel more more healthy
like I said uh and you just feel good to
be to help you know I'm I'm angry
everything we go every day what about
that triple that you hit just a few
moments ago I thought it was leaving the
yard you thought it was leaving the yard
we all watched it together it just
missed and we all wish what that the
tall wall in right field was maybe five
feet shorter I wish but uh yeah I
thought I thought it was a homer you
know but as soon as I I realized it
wasn't going to hit the water I just
started running hot
yep stack has power by Google Cloud
there it is Jorge and that would have
left the yard in seven other ballparks
oh wow and we're showing it now you end
up with a triple you'll take it you pick
up the W and now you also pick up a
trophy there it is the YouTube player of
the game how does it feel you feel great
you two player of the game I watch I
watch a lot of YouTubers
yeah family's gonna love that so you'll
get the trophy it'll have your name
engraved in it and obviously the YouTube
button right there at the top of the
trophy but you pick it up there nice
click I love it uh congratulations on
winning that award and also what has it
meant to you to be as I called during
the Home Run really the rock of the
offense this year I know Nelson Cruz has
been a big part of this organization for
the last few seasons but he does move on
to the Tampa Bay Rays for now so you're
the guy that players are turning to as
the steady Force One of the veteran
presences I feel good you know
I trying to I trying to get everybody
together I try to have a good chemistry
I trying to be a good teammate with
everybody here
um and we're just trying to move forward
you know I'm I'm trying to win every day
palaka you made huge strides at second
base
after playing shortstop for a few years
in the major leagues how has how has
that transition been for you
it's been good uh as soon as I I have
thought I'm gonna move to Circle I just
started working on it uh you know I went
to Sprint training and um and did my
best to get comfortable
um it was quick
I feel really good playing second base
that's good you have to promise me that
I'm gonna be able to take a picture with
you and that trophy okay
I promise you that he's an All-Star he's
got the trophy and hey it was you up
against Bailey over and I think it's
only fair that we give some credit to
what the pitching was like today the
bullpen was lights out but let's start
with the big rookie on the mound and I
mean big he's tall Bailey over and he
uses his size what does he looked like
on the mound lately and I'm glad I'm
sure you're glad you don't have to face
him right yeah I mean he he looks really
good and today watch is special for him
he threw the really good he he command
his creature he he didn't miss I think
he this was one of his best album
it's probably nice too to play behind
him because he works pretty quickly yes
it is it is yeah he picks up the pace
and we appreciate it Jorge thank you so
much for joining us congratulations on
the W YouTube player of the game you've
got an All-Star award in your uh on your
resume so for slugger the whole deal so
Jorge thanks again for joining us we
appreciate it good luck the rest of the
season we'll talk to you soon okay thank
you very much thanks Polo thank you
Jorge Polanco really winning by a
landslide 73
no it's not close I love it Bailey over
to rookie so he's building up his
reputation he was great too he did a
great job but you know as many dub uh
zeros as he threw up today
still doesn't get anywhere without Polo
hitting that home run that was a huge
huge home run the only run of the day
and it's only running that the twins
needed and it was supplied by Jorge
Polanco's home run to left center field
especially in the over under was ten
nine and a half right I mean you had
Lance Lane scratched from this game for
Chicago that wasn't the problem though
just the bats didn't get going for the
White Sox and I think that the offense
the numbers for Chicago can be deceiving
this year the offense is probably not
ranked in terms of runs scored as high
as you would imagine when you look at
the lineup same thing with the home runs
but you really just have to look at the
sample size lately like maybe you should
just focus on the second half of the
season and then even more so in the past
week or two because suddenly Eloy
Jimenez is back Louise Robert just came
back for this team yes Monty grandal's
been missing for a while he'll be back
soon so when you pack it all together
and the stars are in place for Chicago
there aren't many weaknesses because the
identity of this team has really shifted
over to run prevention the starting
rotation is as good as any in Major
League Baseball now the bullpen Looks
Nails and then here come the position
players this is a force well this team
has been well constructed put together
over the years and you know it's all
come to this point I mean what all came
to last year because they were really
good last year you know I can't say they
should have won a division but they gave
the twins a a run for their money in
division last year but this year
everything came together you know they
you know when they put this team
together they have power
they have speed
I'm sure the rotation is probably you
know better than they thought it would
be and the bullpen a lot of those young
guys man you bring up a young guy out
right out of college to the big leagues
you're taking a chance to gamble on that
that he's going to be successful they
probably knew that he had the you know
he had the tools he had the pitches to
be successful but we've seen that before
sometimes it just doesn't work out but
you know everything they've done and
from from their front office perspective
has worked out for this team and they
definitely have a real good chance of
making a Deep Run in the playoffs I
guess you could say maybe the defense
could Shore up a bit but oh all of a
sudden they pick up Cesar Hernandez a
gold Glover from a year ago Louise
Roberts back now he was a gold Glover
last year things are looking good for
the White Sox despite falling in two of
three this week to Minnesota now on the
twins end aside from the sour taste in
the first month plus of the year they've
been about 500 on this season despite a
number of injuries and now missing a
number of players it's time for the
young guys to step up Bailey over is
example number one today as he really
showed up in a big way and let's go
through his start for a moment then
we'll hear from Bailey over but he was
coming off an impressive outing against
Houston gave up a couple homers that
would not be home runs in most other
major league Parks against the dynamic
offense here he is today going up
against some pretty big talents with the
bat and that fastball up in the zone
it's not 97-98 but it feels that way
doesn't it right well my three keys when
the game started what he needed to do to
be successful we talk about his fastball
and him getting his strikeouts with his
fastball pitching using it elevated in
the zone but what made that fastball
just that much better than he did
something else I talked about in those
three things to be successful he spent
he had to spin the ball and he did a
really good job with using his slider
for swing and miss some guys put it in
play but it was a lot better you know
his slider's been better the last couple
times he's been out there and that's a
testament to Wes Johnson the pitching
coach and Pete Mackey the bullpen coach
getting out there and working with him
and you know conveying to him that your
fastball is good but you're gonna need a
secondary pitch and you're gonna have to
work on it and we saw his slider it was
very good today and that compliments his
fastball so his fastball is already good
but if you have another pitch that's
that's pretty good that makes that first
pitch that's that much better and it's
17 whips that's a really healthy Mark
for Bailey over going up against the
White Sox today let's hear what he said
post game with Lauren Gardner yeah
Scotty was very confident and I don't
know how but he wasn't winded or tired
at all I've been sitting there for the
past couple of hours and I am exhausted
from the heat but it pays to be young
and his 13th start of the Season he went
out there and tossed five in the third
six strikeouts of scoreless ball and
that's all he needed
well Bailey you guys kick off a
season-long home stand with the series
victory over the Chicago White Sox how
good is it to be home it feels great I
mean we had a long road trip we started
playing well towards the end of it and
we're continuing that into this road
trip and hopefully the next couple
series will do the same yeah building on
the momentum let's talk about your
performance today an early start but
you're able to go out there and shut
down one of the best lineups in baseball
over and over what was your approach out
there uh we just wanted to attack these
guys and challenge them with fastballs
inside and see see if they can make
adjustments to that and if not then
we're going to stay with that and throw
some off speed away and try to make
these guys hit our best stuff and that's
what we did and our relievers came in
and played great the last two games and
it's been a good last two days yeah good
effort all around Jorge Polanco provided
all the Run support that you would need
and then later in the game we thought it
was a homer but it ended up being a
triple what is the Veteran's consistency
and presence Venture Club this season
yeah it's great I mean that's just who
he is that's who Polo
is going to be every single day you know
what you're going to get he's a guy
that's going to give us give us his all
every single at bat and you know he can
do something special like that every
time he gets up there so it's always
really fun watching him play speaking of
veterans you host a weekend series with
the Rays it's going to be Nelson Cruz
back in Minnesota what kind of
homecoming do you think he'll receive oh
he'll get standing ovations for sure
he's a great guy great player we miss
him here but it'll be it'll be fun
throwing against him I know these guys
will try to mix in some stuff maybe
change stuff up just because they know
each other a little bit but it's it's
always cool when you see old teammates
come in and play you yeah the games and
Chip will definitely be on point the
White Sox are firmly in the driver's
seat in your division what role do you
see your Club playing down the stretch
we're going to go in every single day
trying to win
um that's the only way you can get
better there's no reason to fold I know
it's been a tough season but we're going
to try to get better every single day
and carry this out until next season
Bailey congratulations on the outing
thanks for your time thank you la Troy I
think Ober echoed what rockobelli was
telling us prior to the start of this
contest that they're not just going to
lay down give up they're not going to
lose the clubhouse and they're going to
focus on the youth that's something we
didn't really touch on but he
restructured some of the days here at
the Ballpark to focus on fundamentals
and begin that rebuilding process and
side note of course I had to ask him did
you play basketball of course he did he
said he was actually very good but
pitching was his thing
of course you have to ask when you're
6869 oops yes no yes thank you Lauren
Lauren you look like Wes Johnson
standing next to
um Bailey Ober with your height
so does pretty much everyone let's be
real
no that's true you're a tall dude he
makes me feel small he makes me feel
small he does he's one of the tallest in
the biz right now and look run
prevention when it works for Minnesota
really keeping the opponents to five
runs or less
they're by far a playoffs 47 up 21 down
the problem is six plus and it's
happened quite often this season three
and 44. you're looking at the splits by
runs allowed in 2021 pitching has been
the problem for Minnesota you thought
you would see better from some of the
rotation and the bullpen as well but hey
the twins are playing inspiring baseball
down the stretch that includes a w today
one nothing much more from the post game
show in a moment
he just smokes it
forget about it
great baseball right there and that
one's gonna go that ball is crushed
and this is gonna do it
strike three
[Applause]
great play
I talked about his Fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is what they came for
[Applause]
sure
[Applause]
from the cornfields of Iowa the Field of
Dreams plays host to the Yankees and the
White Sox
in the game of baseball there was a
special place
a place found deep inside anyone who's
ever put bat to ball
a place built by tradition
and lit by the Warm Glow of memory
a place where the Boys of Summer dream
about fall
[Music]
no matter what Jersey they wear
this is where they play their best
a cherished and fertile Proving Ground
where Legends are cultivated
a field of dreamers
they come to fulfill a promise to
themselves
to write an epic story on diamond-shaped
pages
awards are for the mantle
numbers for the history books
this
this is about the game
[Music]
every generation has their chance to
rewrite the mythology
to add the present
to our pastime
to succumb to the Eternal rhythms of six
four three
it's as pure as the smile on a face and
as powerful as history in the making
and no matter where the game is taken
them they still long to come back they
have built it and now we have come
it is in heaven
but it's pretty darn close
it's gonna look like heaven I mean it's
gonna be awesome tomorrow for the first
time ever we have a game being played in
Iowa on the property where the Field of
Dreams was shot and like LaTroy
mentioned if you were listening during
the game 1989 is when that film came out
it's still being talked about and we are
going to see unique components in that
game that you've never witnessed in a
Major League Baseball contest including
the structure of the ballpark the
dimensions I've heard are pretty tight
so that could produce some long balls
and it could produce some baseballs that
really disappear into the fields I'm
looking forward to it I don't watch many
games other than Twins game sure I'm
definitely going to tune in because like
you said that movie
feel the drink it has stood the test of
time and Dyersville was I think it's 240
miles from Target Field to to fill the
dreams and it's gonna be a great day you
know to watch and those people in Middle
America middle Iowa you know the the
influx of you know money that's going to
be thrown into it into that area it's
going to be huge not just on the field
off the field it's gonna be it's gonna
be nice for that area 8 000 fans will be
lucky enough to watch that one it is a
hot ticket I can tell you it is a sold
out ticket it is tough to find any
tickets for that one as you can imagine
I kind of tech see what the temperature
is going to be oh I'm sure it's going to
be hot too hopefully the humidity is
down yeah and it's a night game In
fairness under the lights so maybe it'll
be a little cooler and you'll have two
contenders going at it in the Yankees
and the White Sox let's check out the
postseason picture Chicago as we've
talked about a few times leading
division uh it's a 10 game lead at the
moment as they fall to Minnesota today
but you also have a yankee team hungry
right now and they are fighting for a
division to an extent I mean they're
seven games back with competitive teams
in front of them but they're two games
away from a wild card seat and it's
their rival the Boston Red Sox who they
meet up with early next week by the way
but the Yankees match up against Chicago
for one tomorrow then they'll have an
off day to give them a break and some
travel to get back to Chicago to play
two more Saturday and Sunday against the
White Sox Yankees will play the angels
on Monday and then the Red Sox in a
series next week so I mean you've got
two big teams too I would say two of the
bigger teams I mean when you look at how
big boy Jimenez is and Luis Robert and
Jose Abreu and then I mean the Yankees
with the judge and Stanton and Rizzo
currently on the IL Joey Gallo joins
that team as well that's why I mean it
is going to be I keep using the word
aesthetically pleasing I mean you're
looking at big dudes showing up at the
Ballpark bigger dudes than the ones that
we saw in the movie I will say too who
appeared back from the Shadows put it
that way well they're going to be some
star power there yeah you know you got
guys like Tim Anderson Abreu Stanton
um well judge
um Taurus I think is on the is he only
Torres is on the island yep he heard his
thumb but Lance Lynn will be starting
he's a big boy in the mound and he's a I
would say Cy Young front runner at this
point with the charade just a few ticks
over two and he was supposed to go today
what happened was Carlos Rodan has been
scratched some shoulder soreness really
and they're hoping he's back after the
couple weeks on the injured list but
they decided to push Lance Linda
tomorrow and the reason given to us
there were a few I mean one was hey the
bullpen's rested let's move Lance when
maybe the bullpen will have more work
which happened today they definitely
received some Bullpen work but also I
mean think about it this is a once in a
lifetime game you've got your veteran Cy
Young front runner on the mound you're
in a division that you've got pretty
much in hand at the moment so it makes
sense that if you don't have Carlos
Rodan going you go to one of your other
Top Guns in lancelin tomorrow yeah and
for me I you know when we're talking to
Russo I took from that that you know
what why Always Lance Lynn on Minnesota
no freaking push no offense but we can
push them back a day and have him start
against a team that's possibly in the
playoff hunt and when you start beating
those type of teams you know that's when
you know you really have a good team and
you you can make a Deep Run in the
playoffs you know it's okay when you're
beating up on the teams that are you
know below 500 and I think everybody in
the Central Division besides the White
Sox are below 500 I think the Indians
may be one game under but you know you
start beating some of those teams that
are top of other divisions who are on a
playoff race that's when you know your
team is up for the challenge each and
every day that's a great call because
that matters about three quarters of the
wins this season for the White Sox have
come again sub 500 baseball teams it's
not necessarily your fault I get that
you're taking on teams in a division
that's one of the weaker ones in Major
League Baseball but right they're about
to go through a gauntlet yes which
starts with the Yankees it includes
games against what the Red Sox the Blue
Jays there are some big time matches
Yankees
Yankees Oakland after that Yankee Series
so the White Sox have a true test coming
up over the next couple weeks and Lance
Lynn will start that off tomorrow night
they fall one nothing they lose this
series the twins take two out of three
grab a jersey and come on back
we had a period there that he was really
swinging about really well and it would
seemed like everybody that I was saying
he heard it he heard it he heard it and
all of a sudden he had a home run one
day I'm watching him go around first
base
and it just came out
of the Big Hurt and from there on that
was it
has become one of the great nicknames in
baseball's history
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't realize how big he is until
you stand next to him then all of a
sudden you realize this guy's a is a
monster
he was just it's just unbelievable and
then what was funny too is one day he
came out to you know to batting practice
at our place and he had aluminum bat
and it was a joke he was hitting balls
Over The Concourse and off the back wall
back in there you know it's going to be
600 feet here comes a big hurt
[Music]
let's go way back
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
MVP last year
Jose Avril
yeah but what what's your plan over
there when you hit him what are you
thinking you're trying to drive the ball
left field right field middle so you're
looking for one pitch or water
[Applause]
okay
hey I want to ask you you never watched
my movie Bellator
my movie
yeah
yeah
that's bigger baby
I have a monkey a couple years ago they
call it Mr Wilson
[Applause]
Apollo
[Applause]
you're the best Papa I tell you what a
hitter
opposite field
opposite way
21.
wow Jorge my uncle
he's showing the power
[Music]
when I remind him
see you next time
three one one nothing get in Chicago
white sauce
today
[Applause]
my boy my boy MVP
that's a beautiful day hey you
unbelievable man
wow no you're the man the Galaxy Note
the MLB game of the week Live on YouTube
post game show presented by YouTube
shorts watch and create videos on
YouTube try shorts in the YouTube app on
your phone Miguel Sano is a future not
analyst play-by-play you can call a game
he knows the stats he's making the calls
game over he's telling you everything
you need to know about the contest we
could have just miked him up live the
whole game and he could have wrote it he
knew he was miked up he was fantastic
thank you so much Miguel we appreciate
your time with the microphone today as
he narrated this thing to Perfection
yeah it was great content I enjoyed it
and he you know I just love to hear you
know see this hear and see the strides
he's made with his English like he did
it all in English not very much Spanish
and he was so comfortable and he gave us
exactly what we wanted and what we
needed today and he he made the
broadcast pure gold and play aloud is a
great show on YouTube where you can hear
more of the miked up content and now
we'll give you the highlights from this
one a one-nothing W for miguelson knows
Minnesota Twins
barely over the rookie making his 13th
career start he's been better since the
month of July of 499 on the season
payoff pitch from over swinging a Miss
there's 94 pretty much down the pipe but
it has a bit of a different feel some
extra life to it
that's pretty good stuff from Bailey
over a one two three first and this is
Reynaldo Lopez who finds out he's going
to be the man on the mat instead of
Lance Lynn today there was a
transactional move as well
there's the strikeout on three pitches
going with the change up again Lopez
picks up two quick outs
picking up Hernandez and he's got it you
know this change of for me is probably
the biggest separator
Strikes Out third K of the day for
Bailey over see if they can get some
swinging misses like you have the first
two fastballs got him fishing for some
high cheese looks a lot live livelier
than that a really good change up
that should be playable angelton Simmons
has it
and then the heads up to fired back into
the infield so that lamb cannot move to
Second wow
big chase upstairs
barely over picking up another punch out
six on the day he strands two Runners
here in the fifth
other way and that's gonna drop and
Jimenez does keep it in front of him
it's a two out single for Trevor larney
that missed based on balls for Simmons
check back to Second it sails away
and both Runners will move up
throw with a slider
it
works
Derek crochet picks up two strikeouts in
the fourth
more in the fifth with a little pressure
swinging Polanco it's going a long way
Engel gives it a look forget about it
Jorge Polanco muscles up and the twins
are on the board first
number 21 on the season he is the rock
of the offense
it's true but what it holds two outs
Eloy Jimenez who's been one of the most
powerful hitters over the past week and
change
Juan Manaya excited about it Luis
arrives almost got in a fight with the
lawyer how did I miss that they love
each other
Polanco almost made it a two home run
performance on the day he thought he had
it I thought he had it but the wall said
no I have it
you gotta triple and you'll like it
you were stranded there though just a
one-nothing game heading into the ninth
as you can see Kimbrell handling Louise
arise there's angle so ninth inning
action Alex collime looking to pick up
saves on consecutive days and this is
number seven on the season for him
Garcia bounces out you heard all of the
pop and Circumstance from Miguel Sano
after the game once he caught the final
out it's a one-nothing victory for
Minnesota on an afternoon Affair before
the White Sox Head to Iowa so the twins
pick up win number 50 on the season the
White Sox are 19 games above the 500
Mark and they've put together really a
strong season they keep getting stronger
as a ball club and that's really the
story for the White Sox down the stretch
I mean there's a few notes here I mean
first off when you have such a
comfortable division lead how do you
maintain your competitiveness well it's
easy when you look at the schedule
they're going up against big opponents
and then also work in some of the
players that haven't been part of the
mix for most of the Season like Jimenez
and Robert you want them to play you
want them to stay healthy and you want
to be fully intact for October baseball
right so you know a lot of times teams
do go wrong when it's time to get ready
for the playoffs and they start to rest
their guys just a little too early and
I've seen it before we're guys get not
stale but they they're not playing as
well because they took some time off it
took too many days off but for larussa
he has a real good pulse on his team he
understands like today was just one of
those rare days where Anderson didn't
play and then makata didn't play you
know a couple other guys it was just
this was just this game it won't happen
like that too many more times during the
rest of the course of the season but he
understands how much rest guys need one
day off for Tim Anderson probably a week
out of the week you know guys aren't
getting multiple days off you have to
stay fresh because this team is built to
make a run in the playoffs this build
this team isn't built to to get knocked
out in the first round that's not what
they're built for they're not Kimbrell
they're going for it they're going they
they're trying to hit a home run they're
trying to hit a grand slam this is the
Year this is the year like there's you
know you can talk about next year but no
the Chicago White Sox are talking about
2021 and making a Deep Run and for them
to be able to do that they're going to
have to continue to do everything that
they've done to this point to get them
with this bigly in this division they're
gonna have to starting pitching is going
to have to continue to be very good
their Bullpen is going to have to stay
solid they going to have to hit the
power and when they're not hitting for
power they're going to have to generate
runs because a lot of times a lot of
teams this day and age most of their
home runs are generated off home run
well we've seen the White Sox they can
score runs without having to hit the
ball out of the ballpark and that's a
plus and their hitters have made
adjustments over the last couple years
as opposed to hitting the ball where
they're pitched and not hitting continue
to hit into the shift if the left side
of the field is open The Hitter is going
to take the single they're not going to
try to hit through the through the shift
try to hit a double or home run they're
going to hit the ball where it's pitched
and I think that's played dividends for
them especially with Tim Anderson when
he came up didn't swing the bat that
well you know it was not that great of a
hitter but he started to understand what
he needed to do at his position and he
hit the Home Run stop hitting trying to
hit the Home Run take what the team's
giving you and then let the home runs
just happen organically yeah easy
consistent 300 hitter hey and this is a
big run for us down the stretch we'll
have a game every week here on YouTube
in person so I got to do that because
yes
I love it and I appreciate it the MLB
game of the week Live on YouTube swings
back Tuesday August 17th that's next
week Blue Jays Nationals coverage begins
with our pregame show at 6 30 Eastern
time it's a night game we'll see you
then for Mr durable LaTroy Hawkins The
Great Lauren Gardner and our entire
Superstar crew all here in Minneapolis
I'm Scott Braun logging out for now
we'll see you next time on YouTube twins
take it one nothing over the White Sox
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]